rep Anna Paulina Luna is a shocking
tweet
a whistleblower an FBI informant has
come forward to the FBI with evidence of
Biden family corruption and they're so
worth it wait wait I'm sorry what's this
we've got we've got breaking news
aliens are real we actually uh this is
no joke a a whistleblower has come
forward a very reputable Source saying
non-human spacecrafts are real and we
have them wow ladies and gentlemen we're
not going to talk about the Biden family
at all because this news is so much more
important and appealing to the general
public so I'm really excited to get into
this uh Alien stuff and uh in all
seriousness both of these stories happen
today and you have to wonder why it is
there's a very very credible Source
coming out saying non-human aircraft or
or spacecraft or whatever have are in
The Possession and being withheld from
Congress whoo yeah because maybe we have
the house oversight committee saying
we're having the FBI warning that if the
identity of the Whistleblower of the
informant is revealed he will be killed
because of the evidence of corruption
that he has brought forward against the
Biden family a major bribery Scandal
which we're now learning involves shell
companies
so uh in all honesty we'll probably talk
about the alien thing but we're not
going to be distracted over what's
really happening in this country with
another nonsense story that pops up
every single time they need a
distraction because right now regular
people are probably watching live
streams about the aliens and not about
the Biden family corruption but we're
very serious people here I mean we're a
little serious so we'll take the serious
news there's a lot more news it's it's
crazy how much news there is
pride month is over already a bunch of
Corporations have already removed their
pride flag logos because people
complained so hey major culture War
Victory the stocks for some of these
these big companies like Target Bud
Light calls
Etc they're going down and CNN is trying
to lie saying no no it's all because of
Market factors despite the fact that
Walmart is going up
so we're gonna get into all of this and
a lot more to be completely honest we've
got Ireland slaughtering 200 000 cows
Elon Musk roasting him over it potential
lawsuits are rising over these woke
companies before we get into all that my
friends head over to castbrew.com click
the link in the description below and
purchase our cast Brew Coffee it is our
coffee brand we're sponsoring ourselves
support companies that don't hate you
and that believe in American values
meritocracy individuality Liberty that's
why we launched casper.com where you can
pick up very delicious coffee I suggest
the rise with Roberto Jr breakfast Blend
or of course you can always join the
cast Brew Coffee Club where you get
three bags per month at a discounted
rate and we also have Appalachian nights
Colombian French roast the proceeds to
this are going towards the coffee shop
that we are building so we can have
physical locations around the country
once we get the first shop up and
running we want a franchise and then
have a bunch of cultural hubs all over
the place where people can hang out and
share ideas so castbrew.com but don't
forget
head over to timcast.com click that join
us button to become a member and support
our work directly and you will get
access to uncensored members only
segments from this show where you can
even call in and ask questions we're
gonna have one of those tonight we do it
Monday through Thursday at about 10 pm
they go up on the front page of
timcast.com so don't miss it join us
today
joining us today to talk about all this
and more is Clint Russell
hello Clint Russell host of liberty
lockdown co-host of tower gang mises
caucus member LP National
booster Dave Smith Protege you know the
thing right so yes absolutely well uh
thanks for hanging out thank you man
yeah and I am joined with Miss Hannah
clay hi I'm Hannah clarello I'm a writer
to timcast.com I'm a writer at
timcast.com full of a stutter today so
happy to be here with you and I'm here
with Brett hello my name is Brett
dasovic I am here because well you said
aliens Ian's not here it's possible he's
gotten beamed back up to the Mothership
no he is The Whistleblower he's The
Whistleblower who revealed all the
information so he's in giving a debrief
right now most likely there's two
whistleblowers there's the there's the
Biden one as the alien one you pick
which one Ian is we will never know but
yes my name is Brett dasovic I am the
host of Pop Culture crisis right here on
youtube.com we have special guest Aiden
Mattis with us all week go check out the
channel there we have a lot of fun over
there
and uh I'm serge.com as always uh let's
get right to it and don't forget to
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
smash smash Let's uh read this tweet we
have the story from rep Anna Paulina
Luna this tweet's got 1.3 million hits
thousands of retweets she says just left
meeting for house oversight the FBI is
afraid their informant will will be
killed if unmasked based on the info he
has brought forward about the Biden
family
we're all very confused by this story
because we thought the FBI worked for
the neo-liberal establishment and the
neocons so do they not I guess some of
them don't
fascinating fascinating I mean I've had
on Kyle serifin and Steve friend uh to
the FBI whistleblowers I I know you've
had Kyle as well maybe you've even had
Steve I'm not sure but this story is
totally mystifying to me because I
honestly thought that the FBI was the
hit squad for America so the fact that
they're concerned about their
whistleblower being taken out I'm like
is that does that mean CIA does that CIA
or the Clinton Foundation yeah CIA well
let's read the news so this is the story
we have from today Comer says FBI says
Biden bribery probe ongoing and involves
shell companies house oversight
committee chairman James Comer said
Monday that an FBI informant file
accusing Biden of a 5 million bribery
scheme while he was vice president
involves shell companies and that FBI
officials told him it's part of an
active investigation coma reviewed the
informant file which she said came from
a highly credible informant in person at
the Capitol and told reporters
afterwards that he will move to hold FBI
director Christopher Wright in contempt
for not handing over a physical copy to
the panel the claims made in the
document are consistent with what we
found and disclosed to you all in
Romania it suggests a pattern of bribery
where payments would be made through
shell accounts and multiple Banks
there's a term for that it's called
money laundering so we feel that this
accusation is consistent with a pattern
that we're seeing frankly in other
countries Comer said that FBI officials
confirmed that the the unclassified FBI
generated record has not been disproven
and is currently being used in an
ongoing investigation the source
familiar with their view told the post
that names were redacted from the file
the FBI brought to the Capitol except
for the bidens now you know what I find
absolutely fascinating about this
the story it's really quite meaningless
because the the corruption of the Biden
family is overt
he actually is on camera saying gloating
that he went to Ukraine and said if you
don't fire the prosecutor I will
illegally withhold loan guarantees that
were approved by Congress which I have
no authority to do
so he just says he's doing it then we
have Tony babylinski coming out being
like yeah they're taking bribes and 10
for the big guy and all that and
everyone's just like oh wow and now this
story comes out am I supposed to be
shocked
I would hope not I mean you cover the
news every day so you certainly know
what's going down uh I think that the
interesting maybe the aliens are more
important
Republicans gang up on Biden he's such a
nice guy how
sweet old man
of like the this stuff comes out all the
time and I'm just like nothing's gonna
happen nothing changes like 10 for the
big guy was how long ago now like
nothing changes I remember the first
time that I shared with somebody the
thing of him you know talking about
overt corruption in Ukraine and they're
just like well that's you know RT it
doesn't matter it doesn't count like
doesn't count it doesn't matter he's it
doesn't matter where you're seeing the
information unless you're telling me
that the actual words he's saying are
being faked somehow you should be taking
what he says uh as the important part of
it not where you got the information
well what drives me crazy is that you
have Victoria Newlin on you know caught
on camera on Mike I guess you could say
it was a phone call between her and
Jeffrey Pyatt and you have that plus
Biden bragging about withholding a
billion dollars worth of Aid you have
all of these like uh you know
whistleblowers that have come out about
different things that transpired in
Ukraine in the lead up to Russia's
Invasion and yet if you bring it up it's
apologia for Putin somehow it's like
that's so nonsensical like they're the
the the ground work was being laid for
that Conflict for years and it's it's
infuriating that to just mention it
automatically means that I support
Russia's Invasion it's like no that's
I'm just trying to have a full spectrum
analysis of what's transpired I have a
theory
what if the Biden corruption story is
the distraction from the alien story
like the alien story comes out and
they're like oh cat's out of the bag
quick this is like the third time the
aliens have been a distraction I swear
yeah like Joe Rogan had something in
2020 right when quid pro quo came out
then suddenly aliens were real again
like it happens every six months now I I
am actually in the camp that I believe
that there is some some fire to the
smoke with the aliens like they've we've
been following this I mean if you're in
the conspiracy theory realm at all
you've been following this your entire
life so the fact that they're they're
now kind of like dribbling out more and
more factual evidence to support that
thesis I I tend to think that there's
probably something there but at the same
time the timing you know every time yeah
every time something happens I'm telling
you we just need to hold out if we stay
focused on the bidens long enough
they'll perform all kinds of things like
the JFK thing like who was behind that
I'm just saying if we can stay focused
they'll cave and give us their secrets
throwing out all of the like they're
declassifying everything in an effort to
hold back Joe Biden they're like oh no
uh Gulf of Tonkin JFK was assassinated
yeah aliens are real anything it's like
in Mario Kart when you have those shells
and you like fire them to like throw
your friends cars off course like
they're just releasing them to try and
get us to stop chasing this and I think
that tells you two things if you stay
focused you'll get a lot of other
secrets and also this is something
they're very scared of you talking about
if Biden screws up enough I'll be able
to find out if there actually is an
X-Files division at the FBI and that's
what I'm excited about I'm telling you
just stay focused the reality is these
people are probably in the scheme and
the reason why they're worried about
getting out is because they are the
criminals
that's it Biden can't do this alone
someone's got a cover for him someone's
got to look if Joe Biden is engaging in
business activities
of course that's going to hit the
intelligence agencies they're gonna see
these activities so someone has to be
going in and sweeping things up well I
think that's definitely true and I think
that the Epstein case kind of
demonstrated that as well where you know
once you have you start to see these
like these patterns of cover-ups that
that don't seem to make a lot of sense
but when you realize like oh this is
probably the build compromat on American
officials you're like oh no no I
understand why you guys are covering up
for them because this is all part and
parcel of the same operation I I mean
the Biden family
it's weird to think that the Biden
family amongst all of the corrupt
American families is like now
starting to surpass many of them at
least in my eyes as far as like being
the most corrupt and and if they if
they're corruption in the attempt to
cover up their corruption leads to World
War III well then they go down as the
worst family in American history they're
the most corrupt do you think they're
the worst at hiding it at this point uh
that's a good question actually because
I think there's a distinct possibility
they're not the most corrupt but
um they are the most inept at their
corruption Hillary remember I'm giving
them lessons if she was if they were
actually paying attention yeah Clinton
would be yeah she was good at it yeah
remember when
you know if you came out and said that
the country was being run
by powerful pedophiles in the private
sector and in government they said you
were a conspiracy theorist oh yeah and
then they were like you're crazy you're
a lunatic you're a crackpot far right
conspiracy theorist and then Epstein and
then Maxwell and Maxwell got convicted
and is in jail and now they're like
committed suicide and they have a client
list of all of these high-profile heads
of state and government who were
flying around with this guy it's just
like but no one else has been prosecuted
no it's just it's just you know when
this story first comes out and people
like hey I kind of think that there's
powerful you know child abusers and
government in the private sector they're
like ah you're crazy you can't say that
and then you'd go out and regular people
would be like oh you're insane that's
not true until it was true yeah now
they're like at least they're not lizard
people they're not lizard people though
yes they're crazy powerful pedophiles in
business and in government but they're
not lizard people
the next two are all ages drag show and
forget about these things the next story
that's gonna drop actually there are
lizard people you remember we were
talking about aliens they're lizards my
opinion is the whole cue Psy up was to
basically Poison the Well on people that
were actually hot on the trail of the
truth that there was actually sex
trafficking of children that was
happening at the highest levels of power
but then they they paired it with a
bunch of you know lunacy about how
Donald Trump was the savior of the
universe and we all just had to trust
the plan and it's like oh well that that
part happened to not be correct
unfortunately that once you start
getting close to something they try and
Veer you off course with aliens Mario
Kart shell things they're just lobbing
them backwards trying to blow you up
people fall for it yeah I wonder how
many people are more interested in the
aliens than than this because the alien
I think the thing about the aliens is
that it has a profound impact on faith
and reality whereas Biden being corrupt
is like we know right you know what I
mean and I think it feels non-political
like people who don't want to talk about
politics will talk about aliens you know
it's harder for people to talk about
Corruptions because then you have to
weigh into like well your side did this
should we do that
I mean simply put the Joe Rogan podcast
will now be leading with aliens and not
Biden corruption FBI I mean look the
story about the FBI saying if our
informant is unmasked they'll be killed
that's a salacious hot political Story
You've got like House of Cards Vibes who
could this guy be and there's there's a
deep throat in a parking garage giving
documents to somebody and then aliens
and now you've got you know a Joe Rogan
style podcast and a whole bunch of them
where they would normally be like ooh
spy thriller story what's that aliens
are real let's roll yeah it does make me
wonder if the FBI isn't trying to
rebuild some of its uh I don't know
reputation back if it still has a
reputation to rebuild upon uh the fact
that they're going after Biden after
they've been so obviously biased in
Prosecuting and persecuting Donald Trump
whereas they have overlooked so much of
what Joe Biden's done I like maybe this
is their attempt to get back in the good
graces and not be defunded I'm not sure
don't they want to get him out of office
anyway is hasn't that always been kind
of the plan to a lot of people is that
they didn't expect him to serve a full
term well exactly it's serving up uh you
know a goat they thought it would be the
age thing and now they're like we'll
just we'll just Hammer you out it's just
hanging on we can't get rid of him we
just have to come up with something else
which tells you how like if this were
true it tells you how incredibly
unstable their whole situation is I
still can't fathom the fact that Joe
Biden is considered like their the
favorite for them like like how is that
even possible this guy wasn't popular
ever in my life he was always like he
was popular when he ran for president
and won I know exactly did you see James
Vander Beek yep I know you saw this
Brett yeah where he's he's he's filming
himself being like you say there can be
no debate the man is 80 and then you
know everyone immediately took it to be
that he's saying there should be a
republican now he's just he's just
saying what we all know no Joe Biden I
don't know get RFK they won't stand for
RFK no they keep referring to him as
like a fringe candidate he's a long shot
there's no way he's pulling in number
two yeah yes well that's what Vander
Beek is pointing out he's like look
there's people that are pulling high
enough that at least make it a question
that you have to ask and if you're
saying that debates can't happen if
James Vander Beek who is really just a
Hollywood you know he's a classical
liberal you know I think he moved out of
Hollywood anyway he moved to Texas right
but he was like six kids I'm telling you
that guy's a conservative he's pulling
like a trolley of children behind him as
he's talking about politics looking
absolutely insane it's awesome but it's
like he's asking valid questions look
there's people pulling at respectable
numbers this is not a done deal the
guy's falling while walking downstairs
he's falling over sandbags he's falling
over just about everything that are in
his own feet and even maybe that maybe
we should have the debates and see if he
can form two coherent sentences and they
should drug test them they should
absolutely drug test it yeah also I
still want an explanation as to why he
wore a baseball cap at the Air Force
graduation that has been bothering me
since I saw that video I thought it was
like an Air Force hat though like I
thought it was something any other
president done that seems so weirdly
casual but I I gotta say RFK Jr did a uh
spaces today and I heard
a good chunk of it and
it's bizarre to me that like like I was
just saying Biden has never been popular
in this country like literally never
um and he's still not for the record
even though he's the president he's like
I don't know 25 approval rating or
something like that you listen to RFK
talk and I know everyone gives him a
hard time about his speech impediment or
whatever you want to call it the guy is
far and away from a Libertarian
perspective Far and Away the greatest
Democrat that I've ever seen or heard
speak in my lifetime he is phenomenal
his focus on defunding abolishing
reforming whatever scattering it to the
wind as his uncle once said the FBI and
the CIA that is extraordinarily high on
the priority list for Libertarians on
top of that he seems to have a better
grasp I mean I saw someone tweet out
today when you hear him speak about the
war in Ukraine it could have been
written by Scott Horton or Dave Smith or
any of the libertarian anti-war
Advocates it's phenomenal his depth of
understanding is amazing even though his
son went over there and fought he still
seems to have a really good grasp on it
he seems to put as a very high priority
to avoid World War III avoid nuclear war
which ought to be particularly from the
Democrat Party which is allegedly
anti-war which it no longer is he's he
is like reconfiguring and realigning the
Democrat Party in real time and I am
both filled with gratitude and
absolutely horrified that he joins his
lineage in the in their legacy of how
the FBI has addressed his family so man
he's he's an interesting character yeah
he really is I think uh he
claimed a lot of moderate to
left-leaning voters who feel
disenfranchised with the modern
Progressive Democratic party and feel
like they have some values that align
with it but don't feel like they're
represented overall I mean he is really
what they need even though they hate him
and don't want him and that really
mirrors to me what happened with Trump I
mean a lot of times Trump was extremely
patriotic he breathed life into the
Republican party in a way that it just
didn't have before and the party hates
him for it right I wanted to actually
make this point too I think that in the
the main election you would have RFK Jr
and DeSantis would probably be the best
candidates because I think they have the
most broad-based bipartisan appeal but
because of the way the primaries work
it's almost certainly going to be Trump
versus Biden and it's like that's once
again kind of shows the flaw I disagree
on the to Santa's point oh you do yeah
his Charisma is like on a scale of one
to ten it's a 13. oh I grant you that
but I think that he has not gonna be
able to Rally anybody he has more appeal
from the people that want to go back to
a more boring political atmosphere sure
but you know what I'm saying is those
people are politicos they're political
junkies any of them are conservative
there are many Independents but when I
talk to regular people they don't know
who he is they know very little so uh
they say things like oh yeah he'd
probably be better or something like
that or oh I don't know I just don't
like Trump things like that
they're going to have DeSantis will have
to go out and be more than just the
governor he's going to go on stage and
speak to people who don't know him
and he's not that good at it yeah and
that grant you that and I think Trump's
hilarious he's incredible he's like
probably the funniest politician in my
lifetime
um but I think I'm probably biased
because I I migrated from California to
Florida to live under DeSantis so it's
like I probably perceive him as being a
more legitimate threat than he is based
off the polls he doesn't appear to be a
threat at all to Trump which is honestly
quite surprising to me I mean the only
reason anybody's criticizing him is
because he's the only threat of trump in
the primaries true no one's no one's
Dying by Nikki Haley no one's going oh
Nikki Haley how dare you run against
Trump because nobody cares I mean it
sounds like she's being sponsored by
Halliburton for this entire run oh man
that that town hall rant she did on why
we should support war in Ukraine what a
joke was the most manipulative garbage
I've ever heard oh she's awful if we
don't stop them there then Poland's next
and basically we we have to risk world
war three to prevent World War III it's
like oh you're just a blood soak monster
like every other she was like we're
we're here because world war three is
next and we're gonna stop it it's like
you're starting yeah you're making it
happen
all right let's do this okay look the
aliens are in the news we got the story
from timcast.com intelligence
whistleblower says U.S government has
retrieved craft of non-human origin
official provided congress with
information confirming that multiple
agencies are reverse engineering the
craft within top secret programs
David Charles grush a veteran of the
National geospatial Intelligence Agency
and National reconnaissance office is
acting as a whistleblower and says the
information on these programs has been
illegally withheld from Congress
according to an exclusive report from
the debrief Russia's disclosures reveal
it for decades the U.S government acting
in concert with allies and defense
contractors has recovered intact
vehicles and partially intact vehicles
of exotic origin non-human intelligence
whether extraterrestrial or Unknown
Origin based on the vehicle morphologies
and material science Testing and the
possession of unique Atomic arrangements
and radiological signatures does it say
when they recovered it no it just says
over the past few decades oh okay so I
guess if this thing crashed just as
Biden is getting in trouble with the FBI
then I've got questions but if it's an
aggression just behind where the FBI was
speaking at their press conference she
says uh the UFO programs have been
concealed within multiple agencies
nesting unidentified aerial phenomena
it's unidentified a dominant autonomous
phenomena isn't it yeah oh no no no no
no anomalous anomalous yes unidentified
anomalous phenomena activities in
conventional secret access programs
without appropriate reporting to various
oversight authorities less than a week
before the debrief report was published
NASA Outlet's first ever public hearing
on UFOs were members of a task force
created by the space agency discussed
findings from their investigations
we had a public hearing out in front
of person who's like who doesn't know
any of this is real but then they come
to you to be on the task force and
you're like and by the way aliens are
real it's like every movie ever yeah
it's like somebody has to be just like
you get hired you don't know they're
real and then some dude who works in
your department has to come to you and
be like by the way like aliens are real
and we're going to ask you to ask us to
work with us on this everyone who works
at Nasa thinks aliens are real you
cannot prove that wrong everyone is at
least open to the possibility
NASA this is other departments in the
government right
who who was the who was the guest on
Rogan he was on there a couple times I
think that that said that he worked in
this department
do you remember who I'm talking about
Serge I feel like surge knows yeah
you're not talking about that guy from
the 90s are you yeah yeah that's I'm
seriously yeah but that story seems to
be mostly bunk if you ask me really yeah
I forgot his name do you remember his
name
he said he saw a little green man and
then later on they were like why did you
say this like as a puppet and it's like
oh come on dude either was an alien or a
wasn't oh maybe I'm thinking of a
different person I'm not sure but he I
mean yeah he said he worked in a lab and
that they had this engineer yeah okay
okay well if he said he saw a little
green man
yeah I can't remember his name and look
it up
[Music]
Bob Lazar there you go Chad's got us
covered they're they're smarter than we
are yes I know a better recollection I
put uh Joe Rogan Little Green Man guest
into uh the search engine it came up
with Tom Green so I don't know what I
found interesting about this article is
that they said that the main reason they
were disclosing this because they wanted
to prove that it has not been the US
that has been suppressing this
information for the past 50 years they
said that this is a worldwide phenomenon
and that most countries or most
governments around the world have the
same information and and no one's
talking about it and I think that's
absolutely fascinating listen that the
kind of the like one of the theories
it's like conspiracy theories are hard
to like it's hard to believe in
conspiracy theories because the idea
that that many people could you need you
know uniformly quiet is hard to believe
right so am I supposed to believe that
some nation that wants into the U.N and
has alien has evidence of aliens isn't
going to use that as some type of uh you
know like Leverage Point like let us in
or we're going to tell everybody about
the aliens unless the UN is like no we
don't talk about the aliens so if you
want into the U.N you don't talk about
well that's what I'm saying like good we
won't yeah he's saying you blackmail
your way yeah NATO or whatever what if
the aliens took over a long time ago and
everything we think about public life is
just orchestrated for the facilitation
it's kind of like you know chickens in a
chicken coop you show up you do the
thing chickens have no idea what's going
on but you make them think something's
happening
it's a distinct possibility that we've
been I mean like there's no real war
there's like there is a war but it's
being done on for some specific purpose
the lockdowns were for some for some
specific purpose yeah well a global
event a lot of people think that the
lockdowns were a product of an effort to
be able to cover up the the printing
press that was necessary or the printing
that was necessary to deal with the uh
the collapse of the financial system
exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah the uh if
you look at the the monetary charts from
the Great Recession from 2008 from the
crash it's there's a massive spike in
the in the influx of and printing of
money there's expansion of the money
supply and then covet is boom right well
there was the the reason that people
think this is that late 2019 I think it
was November of 2019 the overnight
lending rate between uh central banks
like spiked massively and and that
signals oftentimes uh you know a
contagion event that's happening where
no one is trusting anybody to lend money
basically you have liquidity dry up and
then you have to turn on the printing
press but you have to have an excuse to
do so without the entire economy
collapsing so that's where the covered
rollouts I don't necessarily buy it but
it's an interesting thesis
so the idea is that it's just it covers
up for the fact that there would be
Panic if they just turned it on for no
reason exactly okay well and and because
you shut down the economy you you
essentially like you give people a total
distraction you think that every like
you would have never been able to get
permission to print I think it was four
and a half or five trillion dollars in
2020. uh I don't think you could have
ever gotten that permitted unless it was
like an alien invasion or a pandemic
well that means next time we get the
alien infection honestly I think it's
probably In Our Lifetime we've talked
about it uh that the financial plan was
a was to prevent a hard fall to create a
slow fall so instead of the whole system
just breaking overnight and everyone
losing their minds which would destroy
everything right they make it a slow
fall and control The Descent
and then things are slowly getting worse
economically and in cities but it's
better than one day you have a city and
the next day you have just riots in the
city being burned down well the
persistent inflation that's a product of
the lockdowns and the printing that
happened in 2020 uh I don't think people
understand how you know
deleterious I think that's the word that
is for civilization you know to have
have so many young people that now feel
as if they can't afford to ever purchase
a home and they're not wrong many of
them and I just think that that once you
have essentially dispirited uh all of
the young men and and women of course
um in Civilization it's like well then I
I think that you suddenly you set your
inclusion yes I'm very woke I had to
include the lady here
um I think that once once you've gotten
to that position well then then the
potential for Wars as distraction be
increases exponentially because you have
so many people that are are purposeless
and you know yeah disenfranchise it's
terrible it's like a whole subsect of
memes that's like it says like um my
biggest mistake was being in the third
grade during the 2008 financial crisis
so I couldn't buy a home yeah like yeah
that's uh that's how it is for a lot of
people and I think you're right like
it's funny because I'm one of those
people when whenever I would hear people
talk about their annoyances with the
Boomers right like you you know go to
college and pay for your college on your
summer job which they don't understand
that is just not a possibility anymore I
would still get annoyed with the people
who are doing that because I'm like look
I'm not saying that they're not stupid
for talking like that and being clearly
devoid of reality now but I do get
annoyed when people don't take
responsibility for their own actions and
just complain about it but the more this
happens the more you're like yeah most
of us aren't going to be able to afford
a house in our lifetime and it's it's
just getting worse yeah and if you can't
afford a house how do you start a family
if you can't move forward in any way
what is to stop essentially civilization
from falling apart and if you if you
don't have kids if you don't have a
reason to to plan for the future or to
to actually focus on the biggest
problems that face us as a people
because you're now thinking about your
kids and your grandkids basically your
entire progeny
um well then you start to have really
what's called High Time preference
Behavior where you start to borrow and
live in debt and you're not you're not
so much worried about your health or or
achieve achievement or starting a
business or doing anything and and I
think that once you have that formula
well then America as the leader of the
world is essentially a memory in
Hollywood and all these industries are
telling you to live in the now don't
start a family and just indulge your
everywhere yeah it's complete
self-indulgence culture but you can
understand why if you are being told
we'll go to college and go into massive
amounts of debt to never be able to
afford anything to work for Soulless
companies that don't represent your
values and ultimately will chew you up
and spit you out it's not a that's not a
fun time and even if they do represent
your values it's still a soulless
corporation that you have no connection
to why so you can work your way up to
middle management fantastic you can be
known on the internet and not know
anyone around you exactly this is
apartment complex this is why it's so
important that that in my opinion that
the Libertarians lead the way in
educating as to what Central Banking
does to an economy and to a civilization
and and so few people understand it
really in depth that they they they
misattribute the blame to Capital ISM
this is not capitalism when you have a
central bank by its very nature you
don't have capitalism right away because
you have the capacity to control the
most important Market signal there is
which is both the quantity of currency
as well as the interest rate so the
price that you pay for that currency
it's it's devastating to an economy and
ultimately to a culture and this is a
product this is a a trend that has
persisted when it comes to Central
Banking throughout Western Civilization
for thousands of years and yet if you
bring it up to somebody that's recent
college grad they'll just be like no
it's the greedy Goldman it's like no no
those dudes are a product of Central
Banking BlackRock and it's nine trillion
dollars is a product of Central Banking
if you think they do that because
they're not educated like they don't
have any kind of financial literacy they
don't understand economics the schools
are teaching them different that's
really the problem is Advocates that
schools don't teach us at all they
prefer to pad their education with like
gender expression or whatever well I
mean the primary thing if you get any
economics education in you know Academia
it's going to be Marxist leaning which
is always you know aiming from Jump
Street to undermine and and debase what
actual free market capitalism is which
is just voluntary trade amongst people
it doesn't really have anything to do
with the government at all but then they
they met they managed to essentially
suppress any knowledge about Central
Banking and what that creates honestly
most of them don't even understand it
I've had Jimmy Dore on my show we talked
about this at length and I love Jimmy
Dore I think he's brilliant but when I
talked to him about it he's like look I
don't understand Central Banking and I
was like Jimmy
if you're going to talk about the
pitfalls of capitalism and you don't
understand understand Central Banking
well we got to go back to score one
brother like we got it because I I
honestly think that he and RFK and so
many of these guys that seem to
understand so much of the problems of
the world that the Libertarians identify
too ultimately their Solutions are wrong
because they don't understand the root
of the problem and and I don't say that
as a paternal way or a talking down way
I just mean like I think that's honestly
the issue here is and he was he was uh
you know at least honest enough to admit
it that he's like I don't understand
Central Banking and a lot of these
issues have been convoluted so heavily
by the market like also it's like they
they blame capitalism but they're they
don't understand that what they're
talking about is actually cronyism
exactly and in the combination of
government
We Exist under an oligop oligopoly and
basically every Market sector and and
that's a product of both regulatory
capture as well as essentially a
fascistic Alliance that exists between
these businesses and the government and
the government Regulators as well as the
central bank and aliens and alien
but do aliens have capitalism that's
what we need to know what do they
probably understand Central Banking how
do they build those ships aliens brought
Central Banking that means if you
support Central Banking you're
supporting demons can't oh even from the
sky yeah and I'm pretty sure it's in the
Bible somewhere about not having central
banks or something because Tim is a
religious scholar I'm gonna I'm gonna
pivot a different way to keep people's
attention still if if we didn't have
Central Banking by now we would all be
flying in UFOs so abolish the Fed
[Music]
that's why the aliens want us to
continue down the path of not
understanding Central Banking they want
to have it for themselves and no one
else because they're keeping the UFOs
maybe maybe the aliens came here to
control everything to destabilize the
economy so that we're forced to end the
central banking system
sounds good to me you're here to help
way more optimistic than them just being
here to probe me because I didn't really
want that most of the time when I watch
any show with aliens or any movie with
aliens and I look at it look at their
ship I'm like how did they build that
ship like that's the number one question
I asked like they got tentacle arms and
like they can't hold duels yeah how do
they build the ship that's what I want
to know they hold sticks with little
fingers on them they got 3D printers I
figure by that point like just massive
3D printers that just 3D printed this
will always gets me about everything
alien like at some point we can only
understand them through the through the
lens of our own understanding of
humanity right so we're like how do they
build the ship like how do we know on
their Planet they don't just grow ships
like if alien species exist they're
probably so different from us like there
was some show like hunt for aliens or
whatever and some guy was like I worked
at Area 51 and I'm very knowledgeable
and he's describing like just weird
looking humans like he's saying they
walked on two legs like why would an
alien be the similar shaped which
doesn't make any sense to me that's why
I really need this to get Declassified
because I want to understand it just
sounds like we are trying to read our
own Humanity into something else it's
more likely that some dude got drunk and
was stumbling home from a bar and then
came across a goofy looking dude and was
like wow look at this guy he's got a big
head and big eyes and oh and then he
passes out then he wakes up a few hours
later and he's like what what time is it
and he looks at his his watch or his
phone he's like two hours
two hours are gone but I was just at the
bar and then I tell everybody like it
was like it was 2 A.M and then all of a
sudden I blink and it's like 4am and
there was this big headed thing I swear
it must have been an alien it's like
dude were you drinking you're like
that's irrelevant blackout
and did you just see some guy with a big
head
that's just infinitely more plausible
than actually aliens coming abducting
people unfortunately but he's like quick
quick the Biden family is corrupt
you know it's really great yeah right
you know what's really crazy is like
imagine what a duck must be thinking
when it lands near a decoy duck it's
just like this dude duck is like this
chick ain't saying nothing she's just
standing there well this is kind of
weird but I don't know that's all right
by me and then imagine if aliens did
come here would they have some kind of
decoys are there like Android human
decoys that walk around yes it's Mark
Zuckerberg yeah or it's the NPCs those
people with no inner monologue that we
hear about now that just walk around and
they just exist without actually
thinking I think I honestly think that
study has to be wrong because I think
people just don't know what it means to
think yeah because they have to they
have to think they vote they're thinking
they're vocalizing in their head
differently than we are I guess would be
the best yeah the fact that they don't
understand Asian concerning no of course
of course Paladin did like a really like
deep dive breakdown into that study that
explained more or less what it meant but
yeah I still like the idea that there's
people that just walk around that just
don't think about anything because I
overthink about literally everything
because I'm doing like I'm going to open
the door I'm like is it left or is it
right and I'm thinking about this all
the way to the door handle and it would
be imagining people that don't think at
all it would be a cheat code for like
the highest level of meditation if you
have no inner monologue because you're
just already in the Zen State yeah yeah
I've been trying for years I can't get
it empty your mind it's like Beavis and
Butthead yeah did you watch the new one
they have new episodes oh yeah they're
actually really funny and they're
they're meditating and he's like you
have to empty your mind enter an
enlightened State and then all of a
sudden they just start floating up to
like ascending into a higher plane
because their brains are in there and
then like they get there and there's
like religious figures and great
philosophers and they just like their
brains don't work people don't know this
about Tim but he does incredible
impersonations you were you like
recapping an entire episode where we
were playing poker on Friday of Beavis
Butthead and I was like I felt like Mike
Judge was in the room oh I don't know I
don't think I'm particularly good at
weaves oh no you are you are you're
gonna rival Sheamus surpass
Sheamus ain't got nothing which is silly
he's not here to defend himself which is
perfect I'm gonna need to see some
cartoons really quick we're gonna have
to hold a side-by-side competition all
right let's uh let's give everybody some
good news ladies and gentlemen uh
Victory you win I guess Navy removes
pride month posts amid right wing
backlash NASCAR Major League Baseball
also targeted so that's uh that's
basically it targeted pride month is
yeah targeted Prime month basically
ended in like a day Major League
Baseball had theirs up only for I think
like a couple hours or something yeah
NASCAR took theirs down the Navy took it
down because they were getting slammed
the funny thing is they're all like the
media CNN is trying to cover this up
they're trying to say like no no nothing
to do with this it was dude they were
always planning on changing their logos
we talking about the meme is that for
the month they change their logos July
1st it's July it's June 5th
June 5th they took them all down
yo people are freaking out someone super
chatted us just a moment ago saying they
know somebody in
marketing at Walmart and Walmart's
freaking out because they don't know
what to do so here's the best part we
have this story from CNBC as well it
says boycotts hit stocks hard here's
what might be next for Bud Target and
others caught in the anti-pride backlash
this is CNBC saying their stocks are
going down even right now Target's down
right Anheuser-Busch but oh look at Bud
saw an increase of 0.31 good for them
but they CNN ran an article this is from
June 13 and ran an article saying that
the reason that Target stock is going
down has nothing to do with the
conservative boycotts and it's just
economic factors and Market downturns
except for the fact that Walmart's stock
is stable right around the same time
Walmart lost a few percentage points and
then went back up Target tanked by
nearly 17 points
yeah I don't think that the time is
coincidental but that being said there
is obviously uh you know commercial uh
real estate and the businesses that
function out of there are not doing
great so that makes sense but I think
that the the precipitous decline is a
product of the the protests and I'm
personally really glad that it's
happening I think that it's it's been
far too long that the the left wing of
the political aisle had all of the
populist kind of rebellion against
capitalism and finally the right wing
was like all right like you guys you
like I let me tangent real quickly
because it drives me crazy that every
time there's one of these uh these
divides in our in our society that it
seems as if we're speaking totally
different languages or like the the
opposition doesn't understand us it's
like
no one cared about adults doing any of
this just making it Crystal Clear it's
when you came for the kids that you
crossed the line the average person
doesn't know that though because that's
not how the media is reporting it
there's nobody's reporting it as that
blanket dislike of LGBT that's why I'm
clearing that's that that's that's
that's substantially better for the
right and substantially worse for the
left or anybody who views themselves as
like libertarian or classically liberal
because if the narrative is so so many
people just don't like the LGBT stuff
then the average person who's seeing
this is thinking wow no one in this
country is okay with any kind of Pride
oh boy I don't want to get involved in
that stuff and what's happening now is
probably why Walmart's freaking out
because these companies are thinking
what pisses people off is just any kind
of Pride when in actuality it was
specifically targeting kids but they
lied they lied about Dylan Mulvaney they
said it was a single can no it was Dylan
of any promoting Bud Light with multiple
cans of Bud Light drinking them to an
audience was under 21. it's because
they're making products for children
which introduce them to sexual Concepts
exactly the media then comes out and
says conservatives just don't like gay
people and what does that mean it means
that big corporations are going to be
scared to do anything Pride related
which is exactly what we're seeing they
took their logos down the media lied to
try and cover it up and it's backfiring
masterfully in their own faces I mean I
know you guys have made this point in
the past week but it's really important
to understand that these core
corporations do not care about the
lgbtqi plus Community it's not it's all
about their corporate equality index
it's all about their diversity equity
and inclusion scores it's all about
BlackRock it's all about ESG it's all
about the access to Central Banking and
the the political establishment that
wants all of this it's all about 2011
Barack Obama's uh you know executive
order that said that you had to have Dei
departments in every federal government
agency it's all about government
intervention into the economy this is
not an organic thing whatsoever and I'm
sick of pretending that this is just the
the woke takeover of of the economy no
no no this is about the government
and the corporations getting in bed
together and then pretending as if
everybody's gay for some reason the
other thing that's interesting about it
is if you look back at it it's actually
a lot of the people that are that are
gay that aren't necessarily enamored
with the movement call it rainbow
capitalism and don't like it anyways
because they know that it's pandering to
a market that it's disingenuous right
there was a great video from signal
Productions a couple of months ago where
they talk about how woke cap what they
deem is woke capitalism was born out of
the crash of 2008 when all of these
corporations basically the banks all
crashed and they have to be bailed out
and they're like well how can we repair
our image oh I know and then if you see
that great there's this great like side
by side picture and it's like 2000 in
2008 and it's them basically saying no
bailing out the banks and then now it's
like a pride float from JP Morgan in
like 2018 and they just masterfully
covered up what they did by
basically pushing towards an agenda that
they know wasn't for a long time going
to get any pushback from anyone because
nobody wanted to be the bad guy who said
we don't support this we don't want this
and for whatever reason right and now
you see the way this is going and yes it
is ESG scores it's all these things but
to me it's just disingenuous more than
anything it's always just disingenuous
yeah well and and it also It ultimately
doesn't alleviate any of the issues that
these communities are concerned with and
it's just it's a pure misdirect and
that's what drives me crazy and why it
ought to be bipartisan just as it ought
to be bipartisan that the FBI gets
abolished by democrats who are concerned
about Martin Luther Martin Luther King
Jr's either assassination or the
threatens upon upon his life in terms of
the letters where they were telling him
that he should kill himself or from the
right wing where it's like okay yeah you
have the FBI which has been persecuting
and essentially attempting to you know
soft coo Donald Trump since 2015 him as
a Trader exactly and or covering up for
Hunter Biden's laptop or you know the
list goes on and on it's like these
ought to be by part Artisan issues the
left otta also hate ESG this isn't doing
anything that you want to see in the
world ultimately it is creating the very
monopolies that you claim to be fighting
you know they're creating them they love
Disney even though they hate
corporations it's it's really funny
there's a great amount of kind of
cognitive dissonance with a lot of it
they they don't understand that a lot of
these corporations that they claim to
hate but then they love other ones so it
doesn't actually make any sense I think
it's a symptom of the self-indulgence
culture right like they can't see past
the fact that they may be part of that
group or they don't want to seem like
the hateful person they can't see the
other implications of why this business
is happening because if they don't buy
the pride merch if they don't
participate then they themselves are a
bad person there's no long-term thinking
really and that's what I find most
interesting I think you know we all can
recognize that especially gay marriage
with one of the fastest shifting
cultural issues uh of anything I don't
think anything compares to the way that
especially Our Generation younger
Generations just got on board we're like
yep everyone should be able to get
married sounds good uh this was not true
for the transgender movement and I think
that is what is uh the splintering point
here instead of it becoming like a more
embracive embracing uh open-minded
Community they started pushing things
that people felt uncomfortable with and
were willing to speak out about I don't
think they realize that that uh adult
consenting adults acting and behaving
and getting married was completely
different from uh gender ideology that
has to be introduced before puberty
there's a lot of authoritarian Notions
and all that like we it's we're not that
long off of bake the cake that wasn't
that long ago that was what 2016. yeah I
mean it's ongoing yeah but the original
case was 2016 gay marriage was legalized
when in
2012 2013 I thought so yeah like there's
a lot of authoritarian newspapers in uh
2014 I thought okay so so that's not
that long off that right so a lot of
those like they were persecuted for a
period of time at least in the older
Generations right the older generation
uh people in that group were persecuted
amongst other people and I do think that
there is a lot of fear out of the like
what does James Lindsey point out
because it's the Specter of the dad not
accepting the the gay son right there's
a lot of fear there but that's not the
reality in a lot of places that we live
in anymore like my generation was not
raised to think that way we still don't
think that way but the problem is
there's no Nuance there anymore let's
also clarify the government is never
going to make your dead accept you no
that's not how it works and I think that
that's a big problem with these folks is
that like because they've dealt with a
culture that was very antagonistic
towards their lifestyle they have turned
towards the government and kind of
replaced their father in that in that
way and it's it's extraordinarily
unhealthy and I'm not speaking broadly
here there are obviously lots of gay and
trans people that don't feel that way
but I do think that that is a big reason
that the left uh kind of has replaced
both God as well as their father uh with
the state family in general 2015. okay
okay wow Mary always gets that one right
she always says 2015 like that doesn't
sound right to me but apparently it was
2015. yeah I thought it was earlier yeah
so did I but that's uh like that's the
thing right they've been like they don't
they recruit very well because they push
out family they push out the concept of
any type of religion and if you don't or
sorry no sorry one one specific type of
religion they're they're much more
tolerant of the of the other religions
depending on when they're talking about
it and who they're talking about it with
but in this case there's a there's a big
push away from family in those cases
because they want you to be reliant on
the government and they want you to see
the government as your family as your
parents those are all prerequisites for
joining a cult what you just described
is what you do when you're trying to
groom someone into a cult is you offer
them basically one way one way out you
you alienate them from their friends and
their family make them fear the outside
and make them fear the outside exactly
yeah I I mean I think with uh the
expansion of the lgbtq plus all of the
letters Community they really did miss
the point of what was happening in in
culture right they just thought I mean
it's very sort of greedy of them to be
like we'll just continue to include more
things and more people feel marginalized
and then run to us and feel a part of it
I just wrote this story today uh the
alliance defending Freedom uh was
representing a dad who's a Middle School
soccer coach in Vermont and his daughter
was a freshman in high school a
biological male who identifies as female
another teenager was allowed to change
in the locker room with all the girls
she told her friends like that feels
uncomfortable he's a dude he shouldn't
be in here she got reported to the
school she got suspended she had to take
part in an equity Circle or strong
session it was crazy her dad who's a
coach in the school district defended
her on Facebook and he got suspended
without pay until and then so that
happened uh end of last year he just got
a settlement for like 125 thousand
dollars he they have to take down all of
the uh gender related stuff in the
school off its website I mean we can see
that there is a different current
happening with this
end of the alphabet they have talked on
to this original group I think we didn't
see this with you know issues like gay
marriage because number one it affected
adults predominantly and it didn't have
to be introduced in schools to children
I think this is where you know if you're
trying to promote ESG you should have
been able to see this train wreck coming
because there these things are not the
same even though you put all of the
letters together yeah well I think this
that kind of stems more back into the
progressivist ideology where like you
just never you're never content and and
you always go faster and you always want
to go after the youth because they're
the most malleable and that and that's
where the line was drawn by the parents
it's like you cannot come for our kids
we will stop you and a lot of people
felt that like look when we legalized
gay marriage that was the last great
civil rights battle right right what do
we now we need a new victim class yeah
we need more people to be oppressed and
uh and I just like it's it's also I
think a big part of this is like there's
plenty of good people who just don't
understand that this is going on that
this type of war is going on within that
Community I was looking at a meme
earlier today from a friend of mine
who's a good person is absolutely a
fantastic person and the meme says it's
a picture of a rainbow and it says like
boycott the sky they're turning the sky
gay what they're do like this is a
person who doesn't understand the
nuances of the argument right they don't
understand that I don't care if you and
adult are gay and do whatever you want I
don't care I care that you're pushing an
ideology on children who cannot consent
to That civilization and so so the way I
explain it there's this video that's
going around where it shows a bunch of
school children waving Pride flags and
marching in the school and the reason
why I explain uh there's a tweet from
Tim hydecker where he said you know
Screw you Matt Walsh the goal is to
normalize this for kids okay and so I
try to explain listen
that's grooming all right literally what
the school is doing is grooming they may
be unwitting accomplices to The Grooming
process but they are and there's it's
one thing to show a child the rainbow
and say Rainbows are in the sky and
they're pretty that's not grooming it's
another thing to say here's a rainbow
with the intent of explaining to you
adult sexuality
so grooming what the these people try to
like I gotta say Tim Heidecker really
does Jump Right In to what the purpose
of grooming is 100 the purpose of
grooming is so that you can introduce
one step at a time from the lightest
introduction to the hard most hardcore
elements slowly over time it's not
grooming if you were to walk up to a
person and say let me explain to you gay
sex and these things in this book that's
not grooming that's overt that's you
going and saying I want to show you this
thing so if you were going to uh uh
introduce these Concepts to a child
innocently oh it's just Pride Love Is
Love that's the first step in what well
what does the L stand for what does the
B and the G stand for these are adult
sexual preferences children don't need
to learn about these things until after
they learn about the general birds and
the bees so why is that children who are
under that age are being introduced to
this type of these types of ideas and
more importantly
there's a video of a pride parade in
West Hollywood where there there are two
adult men performing sex acts on each
other mainly one guy and another guy
it's BD set BDSM Kink foreplay not like
anything super gratuitous but it is a
sex act a foreplay BDSM in front of the
public on a a truck in the parade
spanking him with with flogging him and
you know his his bare ass in front of
everybody including children yeah that's
grooming but that's level two level one
is look at the rainbow isn't the rainbow
pretty the rainbow's great you should
come to a pride event and see how
awesome it is then when they go to the
pride event what do they see they see
foreplay in BDSM that is why it is
grooming so if they're now showing the
stuff in the front of a Target store
Pride flags and all that stuff no
they're not saying Love Is Love they're
saying the next phase in The Grooming
process is to introduce children to to
what they're doing on the streets and
then where do you go from there you get
kids doing drag where they're ripping
their clothing off on stage in gay bars
for money which has already happened so
then you get someone like Tim Heidecker
who I assume is probably just a very
ignorant cultist he doesn't know any of
this he hasn't ever read any about it
anything about it all he knows is that
he's on Twitter and everyone around him
says it's totally fine it's totally
normal accept it so then he just says
yeah yeah and starts tweeting about it
or it's possible he actually is super
down with grooming kids because he's
into kids or something like that but
like let me just say it once again once
again simply you show a child a rainbow
and say Rainbows are pretty not grooming
you show a child a rainbow and say do
you know what love is do you know what
pride is do you know what lesbian means
yeah that's that's grooming that's what
they're doing and those conversations
should be had when the parent is ready
with their child and I think that the
the big problem is that many
progressives and essentially the entire
Democratic party as well as some on the
Republican side too think that public
schools are there to raise you your kid
and that is not the purpose it is to
educate them on the Bare Bones of how to
be uh you know to become an adult and be
a functioning person in the world it's
not to teach them about sex it's not to
teach them about who you know sexual
orientation or any of this other stuff
and and the fact that they would do it
surreptitiously is such a just backstab
to the parents and the fact that the and
then to have the FBI investigate these
parents is just unspeakably evil is
modeling bad
no of course not
what kind of model lifestyle so you show
up and you wear like a a frilly sundress
and you make cookies and they take
pictures of you and then they sell in a
catalog cookware lifestyle modeling no
big deal you're wearing a suit and
you're you've got a briefcase and you're
smiling modeling is totally great we've
all heard the stories about young women
who will be approached online by someone
or see an ad that says come be a model
and then fly out or a modeling agency
you know how it works here's what we've
worked with and then what do the women
end up actually doing because they know
that if they tell the woman we want you
to be a prostitute on camera
they'll say no you have to groom them by
saying modeling is a totally normal
thing that everyone knows and loves now
hold on if a modeling agent goes to a
mother who has a small child and says
I think your kid should model I rep I
work with this agency we do a whole
bunch of different products is that
grooming no of course not kids model all
the time but what if the person's
intention is to expose that child to
something sexual now you understand
grooming and that's what they're doing
at these products and that's what
Epstein was doing as well well and I
think that's a great example I would
also point out that a lot of parents are
already aware that people who are likely
to groom your children are people who
have regular access to them so it might
be someone that you're working with in a
professional capacity but it it could be
their coach it could be anyone at their
school it could be a babysitter you
leave them with like that's why parents
have to be so Vigilant I can understand
the fear right but
just because the school says oh we're an
authority and we're kid is supposed to
know this like if you as a parent feel
like hey I don't think they're old
enough to be talking about sexual
orientation I don't think this
conversation about gender is
age-appropriate like that's why we need
more parents to get involved in school
boards because you guys know what's best
for your children and I think that's
where so many parents feel like they're
trusting the experts I'm not a teacher I
don't know anything well you're doing
your kid and you should speak up and a
lot of the teachers the worst of the
worst of the ones that say you should
trust us we're the authority and you've
seen those posts before and that's just
you should just let the teachers teach
there are probably lots of wonderful
teachers right it's not every single one
there should be cameras in every single
school and some I'm sure are decent
people right for the parents yeah
this is one of the big problems that
came with online schooling that teachers
got upset because parents were like wait
what are you teaching that wasn't a
problem that was great problems for the
teachers for the schools because they're
having school in their living room and
they're suddenly much more engaged with
what their kid is is hearing and what
they're being told uh I just find this
to be the most obvious solution right
imagine it's going being a parent and
overhearing as you're making breakfast
the teachers say don't tell your parents
do you know what gay means well when a
man loves another man he takes his pants
off don't tell your parents I told you
this and you're like you're like the dad
of the mommy there I'm going like what
the you walk and you're like what is
this
and that was happening to a lot of
people that's the biggest silver lining
of the lockdowns was so many of the
parents sitting at home realizing
exactly what kind of indoctrination
process their child was being put
through and and finally putting their
foot down I mean on top of the fact that
they were being Force masked and then
ultimately forced a medication upon them
it's like they you just realize that
you're entrusting a bunch of
untrustworthy people to raise to rear
your child strangers you don't actually
not exist about untrustworthy but just
strangers right and like we took a lot
of parents took for granted for a long
time that you just assumed that like I
like I'm thinking back to my education I
don't know if my parents ran any
background checks on any school I went
to they just figured you know you went
to this public school and and that's
what you did I went to public school in
a really small town and at least four of
my friend's parents worked at the school
and we knew them but again I went to a
very very very small school it's unusual
if you live in a major suburb and you
have more than 200 kids in each grade
there's no way you also know their
teachers no I had a thousand yeah in my
graduating class was a thousand people
it's like it's basically a college
campus at that point but you're dealing
with a bunch of uh look I I don't really
I'm just I'm just so grateful that so
many people I mean if you look at the
charts of homeschooling over the past 30
years it's unbelievable it's like
parabolic it's fantastic and I think
that you know we talk a lot about the
cultural degradation in America so much
of that will be alleviated and and
solved by homeschooling and and
essentially cutting that tie between the
child and the state in terms of thinking
like this is the person who's going who
I'm going to rely on not just for my
education but for my food my employment
my uh you know the language I'm supposed
to use like all of that it gets
brought back down to the basics and you
get to have people that are are form
formulating you know real autonomous
independent you know kind of Americans
and it's not like we have great test
scores coming out of America right now
anyways we're not exactly knocking it
out of the whole system it's not
something to brag about it's not
knocking out of the park where you're
like yeah it's risky but at least he's
getting a great education that's not the
story no I want to jump to a different
story here and I want to start by asking
y'all the question have you ever seen a
uh sci-fi dystopian movie or book where
people are forced to home migrants in
their own homes
because I'm thinking about it and I'm
like well there's the the one where they
give everyone drugs there's the one
where everyone's locked in their house
there's the one where they're burning
all the books um there's the one where
the pigs are in charge is there one
where it's like you live in a house and
then one day they show up with a guy
from a foreign country like he lives
here now
well here's the story from media New
York city mayor Eric Adams suggests
locals could eventually house migrants
in their own homes for extra cash that's
right the discussion took place on
Monday during an address at City Hall
Adams announced their how that houses of
worship had stepped up around the city
volunteering to open up their doors to
assist with giving migrants places to
stay a clip from the announcement began
circulating on Twitter via Greg price
according to ABC7 the new two-year
partnership the New York Disaster
Interfaith services will allow up to 50
houses of worship or faith-based spaces
to offer overnight shelter for up to 19
single adult men at each location
great this step was for the first of
many yada yada he says they have spare
rooms they have locales and if you can
find a way to get over the 30-day Rule
and other rules the government has in
place we can take that 4.2 billion 4.3
now
that we potentially have to spend and we
can put it back in the pockets of
everyday New Yorkers everyday houses of
worship instead of putting in the
pockets of Corporations they're
basically saying
you are going to have illegal immigrants
living in your home
but don't worry we'll pay you
I didn't see that one coming it's kind
of the third amendment by violation in
it I mean that's stating it he hasn't
enlisted them in the Army but yeah it's
well it's not they're not soldiers but
same maybe it's a private property
rights Fourth Amendment maybe I don't
know but it's clearly a property rights
violation there's a viral video coming
out of Chicago where people are at a
city meeting and they're saying that
they're going to be bringing in like 250
adult men illegal immigrants and these
people are screaming like are you insane
how could you do this and it's funny
because the people on the panel or
whatever are smugly saying we are going
to do this this and this and it's just
like y'all voted for it you keep voting
for the same thing you mark the D every
time PDD and then what happens is they
smack you around they strip you of your
rights and you go how could this have
happened to me again for a hundred years
Chicago you have been voting in
Democrats and it keeps getting worse
dude I can't tell you how it gets worse
non-stop in Chicago I know but you have
to give them the 50th chance they're
like oh yeah they're like the police in
Chicago are operating black sites where
they kidnap people and lock them up for
10 days and no one knows where they go
it's like okay why did your grandfather
your father and you vote for it
I just I can't lit I can't I'm sorry
dude I'm out of Chicago I left yeah
because it's like after the crime just
got worse after the policies got worse
and everyone's like I'm gonna vote
Democrat again this time I'm like I
completely relate to your exasperation
because I was born and raised in
California and I watched the same thing
and we just kept voting for more and
more taxes and and you know increasing
the size of the state and it just slowly
destroyed the state and I think that's
the same thing that's happening maybe
not with the outskirts of Illinois but
certainly Chicago itself it's like a
third world hellhole I remember in the
Summer of Love riots there was a viral
leaked audio clip
Chicago's got aldermen they're like
neighborhood politicians they're in
charge of these various neighborhoods
and apparently it's been a long time
since I covered it but they when the
riots were happening downtown they
basically lifted the bridges to force
the Riders into neighborhoods to protect
the financial areas sacrificing the
residential areas well that's what you
get yeah you keep voting for it over and
over and over again they keep doing it
they did again they voted for that far
left guy yeah there you go they replaced
uh Beetlejuice with an even scarier
figure that's even possible I think one
of the most frustrating Parts about New
York City though is that they have begun
busing to the counties outside right so
like Eric Adam believes that the
decision he makes for this major pop
popular city is the decision he's making
for the state right and that's psychotic
basically in my opinion and there are uh
different County elected officials who
have filed lawsuits they're fighting
this but he has decided since he is
accepting migrants he also gets to
install basically fraternity houses of
unmarried single immigrants in your
neighborhoods wherever he sees fit
that's crazy to me
not the mayor of these counties he's
only the mayor of New York City well I
think this is ultimately why even though
people laugh it off uh peaceful National
divorce is happening in real time I mean
the the migration of people like myself
or Tim that are fleeing these blue hell
holes is like that's that is what
national divorce will look like
ultimately is that people that share my
ideology that don't want an over uh you
know overpowerful State we're going to
go and be amongst our people we all saw
last week that YouTube announced you can
now deny the 2020 election again I know
which is just as a weird policy timing
but it's because they're intending to
deny yeah Trump's win Trump trump wins
in 2024 they are going to scream about
you name the country oh China
now because you know I don't know
whatever who knows what Russia will be
they're gonna they're gonna claim Russia
got Trump elected again because U train
did it that'd be interesting well they
wouldn't say that because they're
they're fighting with Ukraine they're
gonna say Russia did it to start to so
that Trump would stop helping Ukraine
then they're going to come up look
there's going to be AI fake evidence
there's gonna be AI fake images I'm
pretty sure newsouts are already using
AI images
pretty sure we use AI images at
timcast.com but they're edited to look
like art it's not like a picture we'll
cut the person out and put them over
something and it looks cartoony and it's
not we don't use it as supporting
evidence in article we use it completely
as just yeah but this is what I I so I
can't say for sure but I've seen
articles that look like it's Ai and it's
it's not the it's not the article of the
subject I'm sorry it's not the image of
the subject it isn't a related image so
a typical thing is they'll say like
you'll get an article and it'll be like
you know new drug approved by FDA and
it'll just show like a hand with a
purple glove like injecting something
it's totally unrelated to stock
photograph it looks like they're using
AI stock photographs but people could
confuse as being the real thing but
anyway I digress when it comes to the
election yeah they're gonna pull out all
the stops
I think right now strong possibility
Trump wins we'll see don't know for sure
strong possibility and we already saw
with the Boston Globe report in the
Democrats war game
they said if Trump wins they will
encourage the west coast to secede from
the union which
which working here what where they
floated a poll of people saying like
would you be open to succession and it
was the South and the West Coast that
were like sounds good they were the most
in support of they were support across
the country but it was the South and
West Coast that were like we are willing
to split up yeah it's like acceptable I
don't hate you I just don't want you to
rule over me anymore it's pretty
straightforward I just I just want to
not have to have to live amongst people
that hate me and that's how it feels now
and it's it's weird because it happened
so like what seemingly overnight but I
think even the people on the left feel
it too like you guys if you're if your
perception of our of our protests about
Target or Bud Light or anything like
that is that we hate rainbows well look
you're not even attempting to understand
our worldview like you you see us as
caricatures like I understand your pres
your position better than you've even
begun to understand there's been more
than a few studies that have shown that
right that people who are right-leaning
individuals are very much more likely to
be able to grasp the concepts of someone
who is left-leaning or a leftist yeah uh
then vice versa because when you are a
right-leaning person you are constantly
inundated with views that are not your
own whether because if you're in an
airport you're seeing CNN if you're on
and you're driving in your car it's NPR
if you are a left-wing individual you're
almost forced into an echo chamber that
you didn't even ask for because you're
never ever even given the chance to look
for view you have to actively go look
for those views let me let me prove the
case this is very easy to prove this
the war in Ukraine how in the hell did
they convince the left that spending
over a hundred billion dollars on a war
that they don't know anything about
these people have debated them they
don't know anything about the history in
Ukraine they don't they know nothing
about not put Ukraine on a map no but
they know nothing nothing at all we've
had lefties on the show and they just go
oh I don't know about that yeah exactly
or or you know oh I didn't read that in
the New York Times so it can't be true I
mean that was what Destiny's you know
rejoined her was to in my debate with
him but that's that's how you know in my
opinion that the right now consists of
the critical thinking folks it hasn't
always been that way certainly during
the wmds in Iraq it wasn't that way but
it is now they're the critical thinkers
the people on the left are like drones
they're not thinking at all it's crazy
to witness that started all the way up
through Obama though right like they
whether they knew it or not they were
slowly pushed pro-war true because it
just never stopped right like well they
said it was going to end it just kept
going they hid that though they hid his
drone campaigns they didn't talk about
the thousands of Innocents that were
murdered from from the sky robots by
Obama but then the war in Ukraine you
can't hide that the people know about
that we still invaded more countries
under Obama it's just that it wasn't
reported on as widely Syria Libya yeah
yeah so that was more Hillary Clinton in
my in my blame Spectrum but yes but it
said but it's it's still under that
neoliberal establishment so a lot of
those people are still whether they
admit it or not uh they were pushed to
that perspective and they just don't
realize that it's like it's really funny
because I watch a lot of old Hollywood
and they are just pro-war like it's
really like the movies maybe from a
bigger director might do something
that's that pushes like an anti-war
stance back in the day but in the end
they still make these movies that still
push pro-us government pro-us government
policies it's just it's Bonkers now to
see people who are pushing it and they
don't really understand because they
heard Russia bad Russia invaded
therefore Russia bad yeah and that's
really as far as they need to take it
because it's a one-dimensional level of
thinking that goes beyond that doesn't
I don't think people want to hold on to
thought that takes more than 10 seconds
to explain we have no attention span any
Crimea I think everyone would be like
that's irrelevant I have no idea how
that's connected at all
region the eight-year Civil War the
bombing campaigns like they're like it's
too much Russia's bad I'm gonna say
exactly and I'm completely fine with
that if they don't if they want to have
one dimensional level of thinking but
don't put a flag in your in your bio and
then exactly like it's one thing to to
just say look I don't know and I don't
care right I like I can almost respect
that more like you just choose to not
engage you can choose not to engage but
you don't get to then put a symbol for
the opposing argument in your profile I
disagree I think people who identify as
left-leaning in any capacity feel
obligated to show outward signs that
they are with the cult remember the mask
thing do you remember the black the
people saying that oh no I you know if I
I I'm still going to keep wearing a mask
even though I say don't have to because
people think I'm Republican if I take it
off right yeah yeah it's it's all about
signaling and and being in uh in group
signaling I did hear people on the right
say look I don't want to wear a mask in
there because they'll think I'm a
leftist as well it doesn't make sense
it's just it's like but no one no one
would choose to wear a mask for for no
reason no one would just be like for
literally no reason I'll put no reason
I'll put a mask on so conservatives were
the people who are alike I would prefer
to wear a mask if they were the opposite
and then Liberals are the people who are
like I don't care if I need to or not
people who think I'm conservative if I
don't I still see I saw somebody in a
car the other day with a mask on by
themselves like yeah I thought that was
long gone but those things I felt your
outrage I felt that day one because I
was like you're by yourself there's
nothing you can be protecting yourself
from nothing at all remember those like
clean car stickers you know like the
back of the car have like those clean
like the clean air stickers in
California probably yeah I like the
people playing the flute with the with
the cut hole in the mask and I heard
people like actually rationalizing it
who are saying like look look like
they're attacking like you're stupid
they're look they need you to get used
to seeing people wearing a mask it
totally makes sense I'm like no because
like in Minnesota the like the state
government was having people do Zoom
meetings with masks on and there were
people who were like look it's fine it's
like they want to get you used to seeing
what people look like with a mascot I'm
like so they think you're an idiot like
what I mean I knew people who quarantine
spouses in their own bedrooms and you're
like you all breathe the same hair in
your house like maybe that minimizes
some risk but I really feel like it's
not it's not what you think I don't
think it's as effective as you think it
is uh I think the strangest part of
covet is that as much as we are like
obviously the mass thing is crazy you
should like it's over uh there are still
sort of uh ruins of this time period
like I was thinking about I was at an
Outback Steakhouse the other weekend and
there were you know they have the booths
and for a while they were like okay you
can go to restaurants if the if the
restaurants constructs extra tall sort
of blockers to keep germs from jumping
the table I guess or I don't know what
but they're still there and people are
used to you don't even think about them
and you don't see them go to Atlantic
City all the casinos not all of them but
a lot of them have actually I think all
of them might gigantic plastic barriers
bolted to all their table games so when
you sit down you have a Plexiglas room
that you're in and your hands can go
underneath it I remember when I was in
Vegas in like 21 and I saw those the
first time and I was like oh I live in a
dystopic novel like this is this sucks
are they still there in Vegas I don't
think so I think they they took them
down but but these things are there in a
lot of places but but see uh you're
you're talking about the physical relics
I I want people to not forget about the
the spiritual relics that exists within
the youth and as well as all of us
ultimately we all carry some sort of
trauma yeah from that experience the
kids who are not going to be able to
read facial expressions as accurately as
others because in their formative years
they were raised with the entire
generation of parents who were too
scared to spend time around their kids
without a mask on they weren't scared
they were doing it because they were
they have they have some kind of weird
cult attachment where they want their
neighbors to see them in masks no I
believe that a lot of the ones that if
they're doing it around their kid
they're legitimately scared and they've
just been propagandized so heavily by
the media that they're terrified of
their own shadow sure some of them but
there's that famous story of the
munchausen's by proxy mom who cut out
her daughter's uh salivary glands and
their teeth fell out of her head and
then she got a boyfriend and she killed
her mom yeah I think there are a lot of
parents who are like the neighbors might
see you put your mask on like they
didn't actually care there's like I want
people to see but I think that you know
Josie talks about this all the time it's
like we are just suffering under three
straight years of much answered by proxy
on a grand scale and uh it just it feels
like the the people that are speaking up
on the behalf of the kids are somehow
being painted as as the Dangerous Ones
and that's so bizarre and inverted and
feels kind of satanic if I'm being
honest and this is coming from someone
who's agnostic but it really does feel
like there's a possession that's taken
over yeah weird but I think aliens are
demons which one do you think it is I'd
prefer to be aliens because I don't want
to go down the biblical line of thinking
because I have some great news for you
just breaking today aliens are coming
yeah but here's the thing if it's demons
at least there's Angels if it's aliens
it's just aliens true then you're on
your own but maybe they're benevolent
the aliens that are brainwashing people
and turning them into cultists no no no
I'm talking like they're here to save us
from the brainwashing cultists that we
live amongst easier it's just the media
it's just the media being evil in all
reality it's a cult and these things
happen and we can look through history
and see they come and go in waves you
can look at all the different
revolutions throughout history for
whatever extremist ideology and they
follow similar patterns yeah but they
didn't have the inner I always wonder
how the internet's going to affect that
now because information is spread so
much farther and so much faster and you
reach people so much easier now that
we've never experienced this type of
Revolution through this type of means
where information is so easily accessed
it's like we talk about like you can't
just deprogram someone now if all of
their ideology and all their cult
leanings come from the internet because
as soon as you get them out what do you
do just ban them from the internet for
life that's never going to happen let me
tighten up your b-hole even further you
have the the debt super cycle which is
coming to an end you have inflationary
pressures and we have 300 trillion in
debt and derivatives markets that are
Global in nature you have the potential
for world war three on two fronts both
with China as well as Russia you have uh
you know one chances by proxy in Mass
amongst the children and the youth you
have a pandemic that looks as if it was
uh came from somewhere else that I don't
know if I'm still allowed to talk about
or not
um
okay there you go uh you know and and
basically everybody that's culpable and
all of this still walks free Joe Biden
free Trump under indictment for a
thousand different things you have
Anthony fauci free does interviews gets
to just you know Carefree even though
he's a government pension of all time
yeah gets books made written about him
and TV shows in his honor because people
worship like sometimes worship him like
some type of God like Tom Cruise but
that's just wrong but I bring up all
those factors to say you you then add on
top of that the the uh you know speed
with which the internet transfers all of
this information and the viral nature of
these communication lines and it's like
we are really like I don't I'm not I'm
ultimately optimistic I really am but
if you add all of those factors up and
then you also put on top of that the
internet and the communication speed and
the increase it's like it's going to
take some amount of luck to prevent a
real cataclysm in the next decade like
it's just going to be very challenging
to get through those weeds in my opinion
you know
we were talking about uh the woke stuff
and I was thinking about this earlier I
think the reason that we're seeing the
success in the boycotts
it's not just because and I think it's
mostly not because people had some
Epiphany and they woke up and said hey
what was this bad I think what's
happening is young people are more
likely to be they're slightly more
conservative
and you're seeing people in our
generation and younger now becoming
dominant forces in the market as we're
entering our mid to late 30s into our
40s
and we are buying things as we would
normally do so in fact I don't know how
much of this anti-walk phenomena is
actually related to a red pilling as it
is related to young people who despise
wokeness now having more money and then
when target has been doing the pride
stuff for for a decade nobody cared yeah
and it is a combination of now they're
doing the kids stuff they may have done
it for a long time but now people are
concerned about the kids stuff but now I
think you're looking at
I talked about how Republicans were
having more kids
in uh it was like three to four for
every three kids liberals were having
there were four kids conservatives were
having then we see that that was in 2000
then it was reflected in uh Pew research
showing that gen Z is slightly more
conservative makes total sense then when
it comes to spending patterns you will
see the exact same thing so whereas
Target for the Boomers the Gen xers and
the younger Millennials 10 years ago had
no problem putting a pride merchandise
the younger generation now coming in and
our generation now getting more and more
money
we are not we're rejecting it all and
it's hitting their bottom line really
hard I I mean I'm thrilled that it's
finally it seems to have met a tipping
point where like they can no longer just
to continue to shove this garbage down
our throats and it's not a moment too
soon I I I'm just curious to see like
how bottomless is the ESG well how how
many resources can the BlackRock State
Street Vanguard Central Banking cabal
you know a line to support these
institutions that have ultimately been
doing what Larry Fink demanded of them
Larry Fink has been for years has been
imploring and not imploring demanding
that every single business that he's
going to give a dollar to implement this
type of nonsense so if they turn around
and then abandon them well then all of
the other corporations that are
witnessing that have to say to
themselves oh it doesn't matter if we
play by the rules if the consumer turns
against us ultimately they're the the
power broker here I was saying this I
think it was when I was talking to Vivek
ramaswamy that the Bud Light thing
happened because it's a millennial woman
who gets it gets this High Roll in
marketing and then says we go woke
but there's I think what what I missed
in at that period when I was saying yeah
the wokeness is not like it's not the
people who work in these companies are
becoming woke it's that woke people are
now getting jobs in these companies what
I didn't catch was the consumers don't
care or want this stuff and so
the infiltrators will come to the
institutions Implement these policies
it'll work for a little bit and then
once the other side of the coin the
consumer comes in they reject all of
those things and those institutions
begin to fail I sure hope man I think I
think that's the only way forward is
that Anheuser-Busch not just Bud Light
in terms of a brand but Anheuser-Busch
has to be devastated by this decision I
mean so like an Institutional American
or uh company it's been around forever
right to see that fall apart because of
these decisions made by someone at that
level who was hired is is extremely
small but understand this
we have seen Bud Light sales drop
precipitously over the past two months
and it's it's looking like it's
bottoming out it's not
when the when the boycott first started
we're talking April 1st El Mulvaney does
this thing this video then you get sales
dropping by single digits double digits
and now nearly 30 percent
it's been more it's Memorial Day weekend
it's May it's summer so what's actually
happening is there is a spike in Bud
Light sales
Bud Light sales are actually going way
up
that happens every summer spring into
summer people are buying more and more
beer grilling hanging out outside if
we're seeing it still going down from
last week to this week only a couple
points
if this was a normal year with no
boycott you would actually see an
inverse picture of the sales leveling
and then spiking in May so my point here
is
if it were not for the boycott their
sales would be up double digits the fact
that their sales are only down a couple
percent means in spite of the summer
months hitting and people and Memorial
Day Weekend people celebrating holidays
their sales are still dropping after
this summer I think it's going to drop a
lot harder yeah no I think you're
exactly right and uh this this video has
gone viral it actually is a couple
months old I remember I tweeted it out
but it has been going viral again over
the past 48 Hours where Larry Frank
Larry Fink who's the CEO of BlackRock
nine trillion dollars under management
insane uh is being interviewed and he's
talking about forcing behaviors quote
unquote forcing behaviors we have to
force behaviors and what he's what he's
not just implying but saying overtly is
that we will force these companies to do
away with their fiduciary responsibility
to their shareholders because we are
bigger than the shareholder we are
ultimately the the only thing that
matters it's not your consumers it's not
your your mom and pop shareholders it's
not your employees it's not none of that
matters it's the big Financial arms at
the end of the day that get to dictate
your behavior and that is their world
view as to why this has been implemented
is that they were going to force
behaviors like implementing diversity
Equity inclusion in brands that were
extraordinarily masculine historically
which makes no effing sense whatsoever
but they started with Gillette and then
they just worked down the line and
finally the American people have had
enough thank god well look at uh look at
Disney and what's going on with Disney
or even Marvel this happened to Marvel
like eight years longer than this has
been going on here when Marvel when we
talk about uh woke women who end up in
middle management positions and then
start pushing ideas onto these companies
that don't jive with your audience
Marvel yes exactly but Marvel a brand
that has a strong Market in the average
middle-aged American male and they'll
always be able to sell Comics to them
but they're always looking for the
mythical you know Target the mythical
new demographic that's going to somehow
magically expand their consumer base
right and it never works out that way
because it's just that's not how that
type of business works at least not in a
creative sense you can't start selling
these things uh in a sense that it's it
doesn't feel authentic and it doesn't
come across authentic because it doesn't
match with the rest of the brand right
and remember they're owned by Disney so
it doesn't even matter so it's a funny
microcosm because Marvel Comics is a is
a rounding error to a company like
Disney the movies obviously are enormous
but the comics are a rounding error
because it's such a it's such a smaller
brand nowadays because so many less
people are actually buying physical
comics and for them now you look at the
movies and like what Tim was saying
about things bottoming out I think the
Little Mermaid for instance is like made
like 120 million in its opening weekend
but when you account for inflation it's
far below what it would have been just a
couple of years ago obviously before
inflation skyrocketed back upwards and
that's another example of what is like
you get people in middle management
companies you know middle management
positions at these companies and they
start pushing these agendas whether it
is Dei or in a lot of cases for this
stuff they're just telling them like
look this is good marketing this is
where we want to go BlackRock and all of
these companies obviously agree they
think why wouldn't this be a good idea
well it doesn't jive with the brand just
like it doesn't with Bud Light just like
it doesn't with Gillette and we see
evidence over and over again that it's
not working but they keep doing it so
that's the hard part for me so what
happens do they find the millennial who
is not someone who grew up with wokism
and is in middle management and swap
them in or do we have to wait for the
newest generation of middle management
to rise up and graduate you have you
have actual you know Comics like Eric
July's Isom which is trying to create a
competitor to to Marvel
um you know I have no idea if he'll be
successful obviously I'm rooting for him
because he comes from my ideological
camp but there's going to be a lot of
competition that tries to replace some
of these goliaths but the problem is
that you can't get financing at the
highest levels to compete with these
guys because if you want that financing
you have to do the same crazy stuff to
compete so you have to go Dei you have
to go ESG so the only way you can
compete is to be someone like Tim Poole
or Ben Shapiro daily wire you have to
like get capital from other people that
are already already successful telling
the truth and bucking the woke Trend and
you guys have to combine your resources
and then use your platforms to compete
it's very challenging like that's why
people people get it totally wrong when
they go well if this was so bad then all
of these companies would go bankrupt no
they exist still because there's no
competition because ESG is a is a tool
to create and and harness and inculcate
the the oligopoly that exists that's why
you don't see competition and this is
why ultimately there ought to be
anti-competitive investigations into
this entire operation because as far as
I'm concerned it's got to be Criminal on
multiple levels
probably never will be
they own all the politicians yes and
then aliens will be announced again and
we'll just forget all about it I'm
telling you if we hold out long enough
they'll tell us some real Secrets I
really want to know where Hoffa's buried
can we just hold out for that yeah stay
keep putting pressure on the Biden
situation to find out about Hoffa they
have to confirm every single conspiracy
theory before they admit that Joe
Biden's crooked yeah it's like oh man do
you have any conspiracy theories left
we've already admitted to everything the
frogs are being turned gay and and
they're eight eight uh subfloors under
the Denver Airport all the good stuff
that's where Hoffa is under the Denver
Airport that's what I heard yeah Denver
Airport one really gets me because
they're like just talking about this one
I've been thinking about it for a little
while uh it got introduced to me and now
I can't stop I was talking about it on
PCC on Friday uh I love that they were
like we have a working airport but we'll
build this really expensive one with a
baggage shipping situation that actually
we don't need like the city of Denver
should be irate if they just wasted all
this money on an airport which everyone
I know who lives Denver is like we hate
driving through the Denver airport to
pick people up like and how does the
story like that not turn into a
conspiracy theory we built this massive
place underneath the airport and then
decided no we're not using it use it
like no one is mad about that
interesting I like it I like the
paintings oh yeah you've seen the
paintings at Denver Airport oh yeah so
creepy yeah and then the horse that
killed its artist and then they put it
up anyway crazy with the glowing eyes or
whatever the giant blue horse called
Lucifer right that's his name the horse
I'm I don't know I that's what one video
on the internet told me so it's
definitely that it must be true yeah
somebody say to Sheamus like the other
day they said isn't there a painting of
Lucifer in the Vatican and he's like I
don't know about that we don't like that
guy yeah yeah but maybe it's like a
painting of uh like him in a bad
position yeah it's like or maybe it's
like they're supposed to go there every
day and you're supposed to look at him
because you're fighting him wag his
finger yeah yeah that makes it bad
painting that seems unhygienic to me
just spit on him look it was a different
time that was pre-covered they were like
it's cool everybody it's like kissing
the Blarney Stone in Ireland like I bet
you couldn't do that during coven no
definitely not I just think it's funny
like they didn't admit the Epstein thing
it just sort of came true
it's like oh well and and it's it's
bizarre because we get like we get like
80 truths but we never get a hundred
percent because if it was a hundred
percent you'd get prosecutions and
convictions of all of his clients as
well as
fauci as well as the Biden family like
so we just get enough to like basically
subdue us and go like oh we're not crazy
we actually had all this right but all
of the people that are responsible they
still don't go to jail yeah you also
want to know how they how they moved on
Epstein if you look up there's about
three Epstein documentaries out there
between Hulu and the other services all
of the pictures him and Trump
oh right right or if you look up him on
Google like if you look up Epstein on
Google Images it's like the first five
that come up are pictures of like it's
like edited photos of him like they're
real but it's like one zoomed in yeah
one's far away
Dad if that's not big Tech propaganda
yeah and how how pissed must Elon be
apparently he said there's like at a
party and then someone was like I'm
gonna get a picture and then Elaine
Maxwell walked up and stood next to him
I think that's that's what his story was
like he was just standing there and then
Guillain was standing there too and they
both got a picture he doesn't really
know her but now all they do is post
this picture of him and Maxwell well
I've only just recently had people
asking for photos with me and so this is
a totally new phenomenon but at any
libertarian party event I'll have a ton
you know a dozen people cool I get you
yeah exactly because I'm unbelievably
cool and dudes with beards that don't
have wives like me a lot
um
so so I'll have like a dozen people per
event and I'm just thinking to myself
like I bet one of these guys is going to
go on to be like a mass murderer and
then this picture's gonna get jacked up
you know because I'm thinking like
elon's one of the most famous people on
Earth he must take pictures with tens of
thousands of people like of course
there's going to be some lunatic that
he's taking a photo with there's some
child sex trafficking maybe that's more
rare but I just I think it's supposed to
runs in though yeah I just no offense to
him yeah exactly well I've been the
highest level of money and power yes but
I just think it's bizarre that we're
like just because of a photo now
especially for famous people you're like
oh you're probably a devil worshiper
you're probably best friends with this
person who you took a picture with
that's what I'm gonna assume anytime
someone takes pictures they have no new
person have been to your home yes best
man in my wedding I just think weird
things come out later and they sort of
are like oh yeah of course like my
example of this always is the Green
Briar uh Resort in in southern West
Virginia beautiful owned by Jim
Justice's family it's huge uh has a
bunker that's declassified under it
where they were going to take Congress
in the event of a nuclear uh faster and
eventually they were like we're gonna
declassify this one so they built
obviously that means they built one
somewhere else so why can't the Denver
Airport have something sketchy
underneath right and later they'll let
you know they'll declassify the Denver
Airport and you'll have to wonder where
the next one is I like it
but it kind of makes life a little bit
more oh I get it so much fun someone
there was one girl the horse is Lucifer
Lucifer for real I don't know someone
look it up so someone said
colloquially name is colloquially called
Lucifer because it killed its hardest
and uh I think there's another reason I
think it's just called like the Mustang
I'm sticking with the Lucifer story all
right everybody we're gonna go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share this show with
your friends become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have that
members only uncensored show coming up
for you and uh you know I just want to
point something out we've been doing
shorts on this channel we had one about
gen Z it's got a million hits in the
past of two million hits in the past two
days A million hits per day for the past
two days and it's just it's good it's
crazy I'm watching it now it's insanely
viral it's like the weirdest thing ever
that the way that YouTube's push
promoting shorts yeah over like the
actual show is kind of a bummer but it's
like two million views I'll take it I
guess it'll still suck in new viewers
for you so that's a good thing I guess
yeah we had we had one that just hit
three million like uh I mean over a
longer period of time obviously a much
smaller Channel but it's like it gained
like it's really funny because it gains
like a certain amount of subscribers but
you have to worry then like people that
are looking for short form content
aren't necessarily the ones that are
there to watch like a two-hour podcast
every day true um and it's really funny
because it's never the ones you think
it's like every day like when I'm
editing the show I'm like oh that'll be
great like this clip's gonna go like
knits never that no it's always the most
boring Bland one that's just like it's
just the most milk toast take I've ever
had but do you think that's because
YouTube is like it's okay to push this
one I mean the it was the the one with
ours was of it was Mary talking about
Jenna Ortega and that was right around
the time it was but this was like a
month after Wednesday was really really
popular right so why that time period
right why didn't this happen when it was
much much more liable to be in the
search you know in the algorithm as
people looking for the content it's the
least spicy take you gotta do the
thumbnails where you like photoshop your
eyes to be really big and then have like
Mary with fake tears coming out and it's
like shocking pop culture Crisis episode
we'll have to do that yeah then that's
how you get it all right let's read some
super chats graftee says buck buck okay
that's a fantastic Super Chat Austin
Thomas has Tim any mobile app update
will buy 10 membership
uh the Android I think they're both on
Android and iOS are done apple is really
hard to get on Apple
so they're supposed to call us
and they didn't so I have no idea what's
going on Android won't let anyone in
here yeah Androids like you go you felt
the form you say like I certify this and
then it goes up and I think they're just
fixing a few bugs but it should be going
up very soon everything just takes 400
000 times longer to do when it's uh when
it's being handed off to other people
that's just the way companies work I
guess
you know my mentality is just do it like
just do it but then it's like every time
I ask like where are we at like it'll be
another three weeks and I'm like but why
I just don't understand that's just me I
don't do programming I don't know but
for some reason I'm told a month ago the
app is done everything's working great
and then a month later it's like it's
not up and I'm like
I don't know no idea I just kind of feel
like I get so much done in a day that I
don't understand how other people don't
yeah well I it seems like a microcosm of
the broader economy it's like I've been
building six houses for the past three
years or five years now and it's been
hell you can't get anyone to work I know
Tim's been dealing with this with the
coffee shop et cetera et cetera it's
weird man I don't know how this economy
is still standing I think it's also that
we all like we have like set goal like
we have things that have to come out
every day so it's like if it doesn't get
done people are gonna notice if it
doesn't get done yeah but they should
have those same you think they would
hold themselves to the same standard
right yeah but having like noticed also
in like restaurants too like people just
don't they don't care about providing
like general service for you like people
just don't they're really it's like
after the pandemic people just slack
every service industry has like been
degraded everything is they close at
tennis service industry workers are like
you need us more than we need you right
there's a plethora of jobs for them they
need to hold on to their staff yeah ask
them to be nicer all right Noah
electricity ah it's a good one has
walked in and out of Walmart today in
Louisiana greeted by five three by five
rainbow Flags straddling the US flag
decided they didn't need my money
oh good for you man here here you should
you should also very politely say I
disagree with the symbolism that you're
displaying here and because of it I will
be leaving please relay my complaint to
your superiors I just want everyone to
tweet their Walmart Pride displays at me
because I haven't I've been to like
multiple Walmarts recently searching for
a helium tank and I didn't see any but
again
I saw one like tiny cardboard stand with
like those glow sticks and I thought
they weren't related to Pride and then
there were like a couple things but no
Flags or anything like that I don't
think I saw any over here at the one
closer to here I don't think I saw any
no that's what I mean I feel like I
wonder if it's like you're going to one
your major city so they're like we gotta
play it up yeah
all right let's get some more Super
chats belly flop says in the past years
I've heard you and Jimmy Dore Wonder Why
YouTube hasn't removed y'all maybe
they've kept you on because you work as
a reactionary thermometer for the
Socialist corporation's evil doings I've
not wondered it I've explained for years
exactly what they're doing they need a
channel like ours to serve as the new
right so when conservatives who are
right-wing as the wheel rotates and
right wing becomes far right Centrist
becomes right liberal becomes Centrist
they need they need liberals to now be
the conservatives if they ban all the
people on the right and then we're the
only ones left they then say look where
are the right Wingers at ah it's only
that one channel they're the only ones
that's what conservative means and you
end up with there's this leaked audio
from some fundraiser for DeSantis where
a donor said something like DeSantis
should move towards moderate on abortion
and say safe legal and rare which is the
traditional Democrat position that's the
purpose you wrote it the way you've got
left liberal Centrist conservative far
right and they want to rotate the wheel
and make the far left the left that way
they can go to you and say well you're a
liberal right yes ah okay so you must
agree with all this child sex change
stuff which used to be very Fringe
that's the point yeah the Moen 22 says
the FBI wants to remove Biden before the
next election so the Democrats have a
chance at winning
I wouldn't be surprised
just put a sandbag in front of him well
who are they going to run if they take
out Biden because they don't like RFK
and no one likes Kamala although they
haven't made a likable president before
I know I've heard yeah I swear to God I
will leave America if Gavin Newsom it's
like I can't escape this guy I left
California
I
would normally say
I don't believe it except for the fact
that El Salvador exists yeah I'm in El
Salvador before he's even inaugurated
I'm out of here I people need to
understand Gavin Newsom is a lunatic
look at look at me in my eyes 35 years
in the state of California most
beautiful blossoming economic The
Beautiful People the surfing the beach
volleyball it's the greatest place on
Earth
freaking in a couple years just
destroyed the entire State don't ever
make him your president America I'm
begging you don't make him the president
please please I feel like you're a
refugee you know Libertarians benefited
the most from Bitcoin
because Bitcoin comes out and then like
all the moderates conservatives liberal
types regular people are just like
I don't know about this Bitcoin thing
and then the Libertarians were like it's
money the government can't track yes
I'll take all of it and now there's a
whole bunch of you know anarcho
libertarian types who are just
Millionaires and billionaires yeah and
and I think that that's that's where El
Salvador could be heading unless the IMF
and the economic Hitmen take out uh
belali or however you pronounce his name
but Kelly I think it's Kelly all right
what do we got Horsehead says Tim I
listened by a podcast to The Daily Show
lately you've only been getting frequent
Febreze can't cancel Pride ads
yeah those are when we have programmatic
ads it's just you know they they put in
whatever but same thing same thing's
true for YouTube when I was ragging on
Michael Bloomberg I had a whole bunch of
Bloomberg ads running on the channel and
it's like
that's exactly where he should advertise
he wants to put his ads to counter the
negative narrative so or maybe not I
have no idea
whenever I'll take his money maybe
Bloomberg will run again
that's true
billionaire Joe spinel says organized
crime used to be a private entity
government unlimited the competition
that's 100 true it's just un-American
the the mob was replaced by the
essential bankers
yeah who we didn't get in trouble for
anything that didn't oh wait for the
Supreme Lending marriage but they just
did the same thing again yeah yeah
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim why are
Chicago residents upset over spending 51
million out of the total 102 million and
that's just for June alone to take care
of the needs of their illegal aliens
they're a sanctuary city after all I
know it's so strange why are they upset
look man
they vote for the same thing over and
over again super majorities for a
hundred years
you'd think they'd learn but they do not
I think a lot of it is just a lot of
people they just they don't they go to
and I didn't think this was a thing but
this is a thing people go they don't
know who to vote for and they just check
the deal yeah they really do and it's
it's crazy because I really think they
should yes exactly they should really
help it they should they should be
irresistible to them they should remove
party affiliation from all agreeing
absolutely should be removed party
affiliation the D is irresistible for
people in Chicago yes these people don't
know better it's irresponsible they've
they were you know people who who are
not involved in uh politics they they
are completely uneducated on the issues
and they crave the D
why are you laughing I don't know this
is a serious podcast could you say
somebody like if some politician doesn't
use that as their campaign slogan they
are making a mistake they're missing out
I crave the biggest D imaginable
or the L that's even worse actually I
want the L no give me the biggest of L's
yeah like then when you say you want the
W you get Bush and then it's just like
none of it works no no it would be take
the L the T yes if you take the L boat
libertarian take the uh Republicans like
Republicans like the tea yeah
T the T you know the T
you know Trump oh I I that's I'm my
brain's office like tea party that's a
thing still I didn't know there was a
story I was like testosterone
replacement therapy I was going to all
sorts of different Democrats
Republicans want the team man
what do we got here Dominic camarada
says Tim aliens do nothing for religion
we already know they are simply demons
keep up the good work
why would you already know that
well you know you haven't even met them
you don't know there was a there was
nothing in mind there was a great part
in an episode of Doctor Who where they
talk about this lady who is religious
and then when alien when alien life was
realized it kind of crushed her because
she's like she's been a Christian her
whole life and it was like science
basically telling you you're wrong I
feel like the scientologists and the
Mormons got out in front of this yeah
we're gonna incorporate other planets
into our stuff this is I think actually
this might be a good strategy for
Republicans to convince younger male
voters not to vote Democrat by actually
embracing Democrats and asking young
male voters if they crave the D and
really don't you want to just go and
vote and just just stamp the D and just
Gorge yourself on D they're gonna be
like no no I don't want to do that I
don't want to do that yes you do yes you
do that's what that's what your
demographic votes you always crave the D
don't you look we've always had the
Republicans need to step up their ground
game if this is the way to do it
you can knock on doors and be like I'm
wondering if you craved the deal
and then there's so much better than the
Republicans that actually going door to
door I never get any Republican voter
you know Republican committee's coming
to my door so if I get some dude who
comes to the house it's like so do you
crave the D Jack Black is listening
right now he's like
would you open your heart for the D
today
General asked so I can make a lot worse
jokes but I'm going to uh read on John
Alaska is guys we are are we trusting
the FBI now they like to get rid of
trump now they're leaking that he's
trying to kill whistleblowers doesn't
have to be true just said enough they
didn't say that Biden was gonna do they
said they're worried he'll get killed
by somebody look I'm not do you think
they're implying on any level like
because he didn't come forward Sumer
crazy conservatives would kill this
whistleblower like what kind of Twisted
narrative are they presenting they're
like no it's us we're going again
have you looked at our track record do
you know what we're saying you're gonna
whistle blow against the FBI are you out
of your effing Minds it's a terrible
idea for everyone involved it's not a
warning it's a threat yeah
Luna they didn't say that they were
scared as in like we're scared they were
scared and I'm afraid I'll have to do it
yes exactly since they're afraid it's
gonna he'll get killed I'll make you a
deal you can't refuse she did say afraid
I'm pretty sure too right
yeah all right
what do we got d99 says Kentucky
ballistics uploaded a new video of the
four bore rifle versus body armor give
it a watch
that sounds very interesting I'd like to
watch that Kentucky ballistics let me
write that down that's probably massive
uh yes the FBI is afraid their informant
will be killed
I'm afraid that he may have may have to
go sleep with the fishes
brought forward about the Biden family
there's an episode of of the X-Files
where the cigarette smoking man is like
listening to a speech of Martin Luther
King and then he says something that he
knows he's like oh God now I gotta go
and take this dude out he's upset about
it he's like I don't want to but it's my
job I have to go do it the FBI doesn't
want to either yeah wait that's what I'm
saying
a lot a lot of people will think that
RFK Jr is a non-starter for the d uh
because of the war in Ukraine or because
of the uh his vaccine hesitancy pitch
that he's had for years and years uh
ultimately I think that the reason he's
a real non-starter is because he wants
to abolish and disband the CIA and the
FBI like that that is so ballsy I can't
tell you how courageous and incredible
of a stand that is to take and to run in
either duopoly side it's amazing it also
works for DeSantis
but is he is he really running on that
though craving the D
I'm saying crabbing the D works for his
hands oh that's true yeah are you
craving the D like
you can't say gay in Florida but you can
crave the D that's right yeah
I'm voting for Trump I'm voting for
Trump I want the big T not the big D
this is all so confusing
all right Bobcat says Hannah Claire have
you finished those movies yet I don't
know what you're talking about there are
no I haven't finished there's a new one
that's even more nice I know you were
supposed to go to us with the theater
yes if you said if you did not shut up
at my desk 10 minutes before you left
I'm saying like you originally said if I
don't finish all of them before the 10th
one comes out we're talking about the
fastest I have to watch The Fast and
Furious movie because a podcast that I
go on sometimes made a wager and now I
have it to the wager
you agreed to the wager but to me I dyed
my hair blonde yeah that's why I have to
honor this I started this thing where
they would reach like certain levels of
Crisis parties and it started with Brett
bleaching his hair but then they up the
ante on me and I have to watch all of
the Fast and Furious movies which I
don't want to you've never seen one no
no okay so there was a while I was doing
a really good job I got this challenge
like six months ago uh and I would there
was one night I watched like two or
three just to like knock them out but
then I hit I think about five or six and
I just I don't want to keep going to go
to outer space and every time
like oh the next one's the best
that to me I think this is like the
thing where when people have kids
they're like oh but but having two is
harder oh having three it's having four
is harder like every time I finish Fast
and Furious movie there's someone who's
like no no but the next one is the best
one you're getting better they do get
better wine it's just important it's
important I disagree with you on that
one I think nine is the weakest of of
all of them I think nine three that's
one with the space yeah but the
self-referential humor is too over the
top that's just my personal opinion I
also feel like Brett is like not making
this fun for me every time he's just
like you do it and there's like like the
people in the chat there's no group
activity I'm just supposed to sit alone
and find a streaming service I don't
have access
like four of them problem solved Friday
starting at noon we will begin a fast
and furious watch party hell yeah I
can't do Friday but if you want to do it
next Friday I'm in not this Friday but
next Friday yeah and I'll do them all I
will stay there and watch them all until
they're done okay then we'll start we'll
start we'll do a full day we'll start at
what seven nine a.m okay But I either
I'm not working or I'm gonna come in at
the movie that I have reached the key
the key to enjoying the Fast and Furious
franchise is to uh crave the VIN D
that's exactly that's exactly right I
just crave the D's of course
there's like this weird incestuous
implication that I don't like like I
just don't get these movies we're
talking about family the reason it's in
a weird way the reason it's so great and
I realized this in the 10th one the
reason so Grace because everybody else
is acting like it's absurd because it's
absurd yeah and Vin Diesel just takes it
he just plays it completely straight he
plays the story and that's what allows
you to buy into it it's absolutely
ridiculous and over the top but it's a
ton of fun it's a it's a modern
Masterpiece and people are totally
asleep on that entire series it's
phenomenal I then I'm 100 asleep
awesome
there's like moments that I'll report
you right like I think I might unders no
I don't I don't understand I take notes
like it just it just gets more and more
far-fetched as they progress it's so
good it's amazing all right all right
we'll read it read some more paulius
Daenerys says I know someone high up at
Walmart's marketing and they mentioned
that everyone is freaking out over the
boycotts and marketing teams walking on
eggshells can't agree on marketing
strategies great they should walk on
eggshells all the time it's so it's so
weird though because it's such an easy
Dodge just stop politicizing everything
you do but apparently that's not the
thought of a really good ad for Bud
Light
that they could have done instead of Don
mulvania get this it's it's like a
mountain right in the background and
there's a can of Bud Light just like
there in front of you and it says
America's beer
and that's it
that's the whole ad we can't talk about
America it's so controversial some
people don't like it okay all right fair
point so it's let's just say it's a blue
tinted background with this with like a
outline of a mismatch it's like a
mountain blue background so it's not
like a clear picture it's like you know
it's like art and there's a picture of a
Bud Light can and it just says ice cold
beer that's it
I think you could go that way or you can
go over the top the other direction
where you're like
America guns God Donald Trump Bud Light
but they tried the Clydesdale thing
right after and people got more my point
is Bud Light doesn't need marketing they
could literally just put a picture of a
can of Bud Light to remind people it
exists
like I said this couple times not that
they should have used Dylan Mulvaney but
they have both light Seltzer which
they're constantly trying to push
because it's not the most well-known
hard Seltzer out there they needed to
promote a product the one that people
are not as familiar with would have made
sense they're classic blue Bud Light can
is the stupidest thing to try and be
like you know what we need to reinvent
the wheel yeah and then like directly
calling out their like primary buyers
like saying oh it's too much of a frat
beer we don't like that that's amazing
let's read another one we got Sean he
says UFOs not BS Tim I saw a UFO 17
years ago in East Texas it was a black
diamond the size of a car silently
hovering above a field in front of my
house for a few minutes before shooting
straight up like a bullet I believe you
um because we've heard a lot of those
stories and but there's a simple
explanation
there was a story I read about it was
like recently Naval pilot saying they
saw it you know on unexplained aerial
phenomena or anomalous phenomena or
whatever and they're like these weird
Vehicles were hovering near them the
ship of tic tacs and they were like
darting around
and then it passively mentions like
later in the article that it was 70
miles away from an experimental U.S
weapons facility right and I'm like oh
okay like so tell me more stories about
how the US is making new weapons I don't
know but in truth like is there can you
ever get more than 70 miles away from an
experimental U.S DARPA facility in
America perhaps not yeah I'm not sure we
can't say but
I tell you about it
was it was an experimental like
Aerospace Technologies facility yeah so
what yeah then you'd probably lean
towards that being right another thing
too is we think about these UFOs these
discs
I'm kind of surprised a quad rotor
drones have only become prominent
recently
it's not that difficult to concept to
have four propellers you know just in in
counterclockwise clockwise I assume it
has to do with computers I I was
thinking that they didn't have enough
battery capacity to to you know actually
give enough juice to the propeller you
can do it with gas but then if if that's
the case then you have to have you know
combustion engine of some sort that's
weighs a lot more so when they they
definitely can do it well I know they
can now but I'm saying I definitely do
it back then too oh okay like look at a
helicopter oh that's true yeah right
they could easily do quad rotors that
that they had like a flying platform
that used like a single fan right but my
point is like when we see these UFOs
like it very well could have just been
early quad rotor technology I mean we
had helicopters we're experimenting with
this true yeah and then people see it
and they're like uh at first like it's
aliens yeah because they didn't want to
say it's weapons technology we're
working on the one thing that puts me
because I as I've already made very
clear I believe that aliens exist and I
believe they're probably visiting us
however how is it even possible with all
of the HD cameras that exist everywhere
CCTV I still can't get one clean shot of
these sons of like it's like
where are they at it's the Mitch Hedberg
see he goes I think Bigfoot is blurry
he's like and that's way scarier there's
a large out-of-focus monster roaming the
countryside
a funny thing to know is that like all
the US testing for like uh like I guess
Aerospace Aerospace technology has to
take place offshore because of the Sonic
booms taking place over the over us well
so the major takeoff offshore and on top
of that that's why you know we wouldn't
we wouldn't see them anywhere except
offshore yeah there was a sonic boom in
DC yeah that was today right yeah yeah
because uh someone flew a single engine
Cessna or something over DC it's crazy
and so they scrambled fighter jets
crazy I just kept thinking about
vampires when you were giving the sucks
like why can't you see that why can't
you see photos of them maybe because
they don't photograph you don't know we
don't know I thought you were tying it
back into my Gavin Newsom Ranch and I
was like you're right you could be a
vampire anything's possible Batman look
look at me in the eyes America he has
destroyed the greatest place on Earth do
not cast a vote for Gavin Newsom but if
you care about your children don't do it
he's still most dangerous man on the
planet do you hear me fantastic for tent
sales though
all right what do we got here I'm sorry
I really don't like that question mark
giving away uh just say something says I
really hate this myth that people can't
afford to buy houses these days I have
two boys 24 and 25 who both own houses
modern day expectations are the only
thing stopping you renting is just
cognitive dissonance
I think the issue is people want to live
in cities that have high costs high
crime
there's how their house is out in West
Virginia that are I would call them
fixer-uppers but livable and they're
like a hundred hundred thousand dollars
and so I know a lot of people are like
where am I supposed to get a hundred
thousand dollars like you don't you get
like you save a mortgage two yeah you
know even and then uh get a mortgage and
then you're paying interest at the bank
for sure but you're actually saving some
of the value that you're putting into
your mortgage every month and you're
Building Wealth better than paying rent
where it just goes away I mean you
basically but this is this is also part
of like why we no longer live around our
families because so many of the people
that like speaking for myself almost no
one I knew knew that I grew up with
stayed in San Diego even though all of
their families stayed there because they
owned houses that increased in value by
3x over their lifetimes and the kids all
couldn't afford to buy a house there so
they all migrate away they start a
family elsewhere and then and then we
lament the fact that our culture doesn't
look after our elders it's like well
this is a product of the inflation
that's created by the central banks but
I I have to it takes more than 10
seconds to explain so no one wants to
hear it yeah more than 10 seconds
brandisl says pride comes before the
fall truer words have never been said
maybe it's chronological but I think
Pride was it pride come before the fall
what if it wasn't a uh
what if it wasn't
an analogy or that's not the right way
to explain it that's not what it is what
if it wasn't
um descriptive it was prescriptive like
what if they weren't saying on average
pride comes for the fall what if they
were literally saying in the United
States in the year 2023 there's going to
be this big thing called pride and then
a few years later the country what if he
was literally predicting something yeah
pride month is in June fall is starting
what late August September so
technically it does come before the fall
all the time
that's all that was totally benign yeah
it was like trying to figure out when to
schedule Pride months
oh man it's hard to have parades in
Winter they were just like before fall
that could turn out you know what do we
got Nathan C says think about how all
the lefties get triggered by words and
how the media trains them to be CNN and
MSNBC use MK Ultra tactics that explains
the left
and they believe it over and over and
over again
R Levis has really worried about the
hero worship of RFK it's like people on
the right forgot his last several
decades of calling gun owners terrorists
and wanting to Gulag people over global
warming
can I respond to that I haven't
forgotten for the record uh but he has
also said now granted this could be him
shifting more toward the center to try
and appeal to people like me but he has
made it very clear that based off of his
experience with the lockdowns and the
the massive State apparatus that tried
to deal with the pandemic that he is now
no longer in favor of any sort of
Government Solutions towards climate
change he believes that Innovation is
the only path forward that's what he
says yeah you don't buy him you don't
buy it it's not so much about whether I
buy it it's like oh how convenient
that's fair but I think he was he was
starting to already sound that way
during the lockdowns not when he was
winning running for president so I don't
know we'll find out
we will find out but for now smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends head
over to timcast.com click join us become
a member because the members only
uncensored show will be starting in just
a few minutes and you don't want to miss
it we got some big stories to talk about
it's gonna be very very good so again go
to timcast.com you can also smash the
like button share the share with your
friends you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Clint do you want to shout
anything out uh yeah shout out to uh
Tower gang my homies if you're tired of
the D being shoved down your throat uh
make sure you subscribe to Tower game
where we'll do it for them and then uh
liberty lockdown if you want to hear uh
really radical you know libertarian
style Ron Paul style Dave Smith style
brandts and follow me on Twitter at
Liberty lockpaw thank you so much for
having me content there's no way to
follow that up uh I'm Hannah I'm a
writer for timcast.com go to timcast.com
click on the read tab see all the work
from me uh Adrian Norman Chris Bertman
Oliver journalists they're excellent you
should definitely 110 follow at 10 cast
news on Twitter and Instagram you can
see all of our stuff it's great it's the
best if you want to follow me personally
you can follow me on Instagram at Hannah
claire.b and on Twitter at HC bromelo
thank you so much
guys if you'd like to follow me you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
Brett dasovic on both of those platforms
pop culture crisis has a special guest
this week Aiden Mattis is in town he is
uh he runs the lore Lodge YouTube
channel which is a fantastic YouTube
channel that everybody should check out
me him and Phil are going to be doing
shows all week with various guests Mary
will be back from vacation the week
after that uh check us out all week
thanks
uh I am search.com on Twitter and
Instagram I think I'm joining you next
week is that right yes okay I've got the
dates up there I'm I'm scheduled okay
fantastic and uh yeah fun show always
good to see you Clint yeah and uh yeah
search.com follow them everywhere yes
yes oh real quick I wanted to also
mention I will be in New Jersey this
weekend uh for icarusfest icarusfest.com
incredible speak up of anti-war
Advocates it's gonna be fun right on
everybody we'll see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out